Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss!
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss!
Das Problem war, ich hab die Seiten ein bisschen schnell abgefragt.
Jetzt hab ich das ein bisschen reduziert.
Allerdings, ich hab auch mal zwei Stunden gar nichts gemacht.
Die haben irgendwie direkt Alps geplockt.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich ab und zu mal ein bisschen übertrieben hab mit dem Abfragen.
Jetzt nicht so, dass es großartig Last verursacht hat, aber schon, dass es auffällig ist.
So, und wisst ihr was ich jetzt gemacht hab?
Ich hab jetzt eine exzellente Idee.
Und zwar, der neue IP geht nicht so einfach.
Also ja, letztendlich neue IP, aber so einfach geht's nicht.
Du musst den Server neu aufbauen.
Ich hab mir den Ansible, gut, dass wir Ansible geübt haben, letzten Stream.
Ich hab mir ein paar Ansible Skripts gemacht zum Server neu installieren.
Und dann hab ich einen Skript gemacht, was über die Hetzner Cloud-RP geht.
Und dort einen neuen Server aufbaut, Ansible auflässt, den Crawler drauf startet.
Und dann den alten Server löscht.
Also sprich, ich kann jetzt das einmal am Tag rotaten lassen von der IP her.
Nur für den Fall, wobei ich nicht rotaten lassen muss mehr, glaub ich.
Hat sich jetzt eingependelt.
Und ich hab jetzt auch ein bisschen umgestellt.
Ich hab jetzt nicht mehr einen 16-Core.
Ich hab jetzt keinen 16-Core mehr.
Ich hab jetzt 3x3-Core.
Wow, mach halt gleich mal Riesenkrache.
Ich hab jetzt 3x3-Core, weil dann kann ich das besser rotieren von den IPs her.
Und ich brauch keine floating IPs mehr, die extra Geld kosten.
Das heißt, aktuell bezahle ich ja irgendwie was um 70, 75 Euro im Monat.
Und jetzt dürfte ich dann irgendwie bei...
Keine Ahnung.
8 kostet ja...
8, 16...
Na, sagen wir mal so bei 32 Euro sein.
Man kann jetzt sortieren, ja?
Nee, ich hab mir noch kein YouTube-Premium geholt.
Aber man kann jetzt sortieren.
Ja, richtig, richtig.
Meinst du, das wird sich...
Nein, da rechnet sich überhaupt nichts.
Was soll sich da rechnen?
Ich meine, da sind ja keine Reflinks drin.
Der einzige Reflink, der drinne ist, ist, wenn Amazon mal aufploppt.
Das war's dann aber auch.
Also, sonst hab ich ja gar keine Reflinks.
Übrigens, hier hatte ich die falsche Kategorie drin.
Die RX 6800 war teilweise die 6800XT.
Und dementsprechend 400 Euro teurer.
Ja, Leute.
Es war echt anstrengend, hier den Kram zusammen zu wursten.
Aber jetzt geht das alles automatisch.
Exzellent.
Ja, und da hab ich intern das Netz angelegt.
Geht ja bei Hetzner auch.
Was nur zwischen den Servern dort existiert.
Und da drüber können die ganzen Crawler jetzt ihr Zeug einschicken.
An das Frontend.
Oh nee, Spendenlink.
Was denn?
35 Euro im Monat kann ich schon bezahlen.
Mal gucken, vielleicht rechnen sie sich da mit Amazon ein bisschen.
Ich müsste einfach immer Amazon anzeigen, wenn Amazon lieferbar ist.
Einfach so einen Filter machen.
If Amazon verfügbar, dann immer Amazon auf Frontpage anzeigen, weil Amazon Reflinks hat.
Rigged.
Allgemein Amazon-Link.
Naja, wo soll ich den einplanten?
Den kann ich höchstens oben irgendwie drüber machen.
Hier supportet den Preis-Champ und dann kommt man auf Amazon raus oder so.
Wisst ihr was?
Wahrscheinlich...
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich's mir einfach mach.
Ich mach einfach hier oben...
Ich mach einfach hier oben ein AdSense Fenster hin.
Das stört glaube ich kein sonderlich großartig, wenn hier oben so ein AdSense Fenster ist.
So, und AdSense ist ja auch halbwegs seriös, was da kommt.
Dann passt das schon.
Oh, ähm, gucken ob Teams nicht wieder aus Versehen umgestellt hat.
Wobei, das hätte ich schon gemerkt, ich war seit Freitag nicht mehr im Teams-Lol.
Nee, nee, er hat's nicht.
Dit, dit, dit, dit, dit.
Prings, ähm...
Ich hab was Cooles gefunden.
Verwendet jemand KeyPass von euch?
Ich hab was richtig Schneises gefunden und zwar...
Äh...
High-Speed-Cube hier angesagt.
Warte mal, das könnte ein Chrome umliegen.
Wir machen jetzt mal kurz den Chrome, da geht's bestimmt schnell.
Ja, easy, guck mal.
Das ist der Unterschied zwischen CPU-Rendern und GPU-Rendern.
So sieht's mit GPU aus.
Und so sieht's mit CPU-Rendern aus.
Genau, und zwar, ich hab was gefunden.
KeyPass-OTP...
Oh, wie hieß das?
Tja.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt finden würde.
Und zwar, ich hab ein OTP-Plugin gefunden für KeyPass, was richtig gut funktioniert auch.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt diese ganzen, diese ganzen, äh, Two-Factor-Authentifizierungsgedöns
kann ich jetzt über meinen KeyPass machen.
Ich hab aber...
Das ist es nicht, das ist es nicht.
Nee, nee.
Ja gut, ich find's jetzt nicht mehr.
Fuck.
Aber das ist echt praktisch gewesen.
Alter, warum sieht das so kacke aus, die Seite?
Oh, ich bin blind, Leute.
Muss man eingeloggt sein?
Man muss eingeloggt sein, um das GitHub Dark Team anzustellen.
Man kann einfach, man kann einfach so...
Die Seite sieht übersproken aus.
Das könnte es...
Das könnte es, glaub ich, sogar sein.
Ja, das da ist es, genau.
Da kann man, da kann man dann, beispielsweise bei PayPal oder bei Hetzner oder wo auch immer,
wo man Zwei-Factor-Authentifizierungen macht, ähm, da kann man ja immer auswählen,
bei Zwei-Factor-Authentifizierungen, so meistens zumindest, ob man eine SMS kriegen will
oder ob man irgendeinen Authenticator verwenden will, ja.
Also da kann man dann den Microsoft Authenticator auf dem Handy verwenden oder sonst was.
Oder man züngt sich einfach hier mit und hat direkt im Keypass auch noch die zweite Two-Factor-Geschichte.
Okay, man kann natürlich sagen, das will man nicht,
weil das ja dann nicht mehr so richtig Two-Factor ist, wenn alles auf dem gleichen Rechner ist.
Wobei man eh zum Thema Passwort sagen muss, dass so ein Zettel echt nicht verkehrt ist.
Die meisten Leute denken sich, oh nee, wenn ich das aufschreibe, dann ist das ja ganz furchtbar unsicher.
Dabei ist das gar nicht so schlecht aufgeschrieben.
Aufgeschrieben hat den riesen Vorteil, es kann niemand, das Ding, ne, du kommst nicht, wenn du irgendwie
irgendwelche Malware-Trojaner-sonstwas auf dem Rechner hast, irgendwelche Root-Kits, Keylogger,
was auch immer, an den Zettel kommst du nicht dran.
Gut, wenn du es mal irgendwann eintippst, ist halt vorbei, aber...
Äh, was war das hier? Moment, zeig mal hier, was?
Das ist deine Meinung, zu ständig steigende Preise von Grafik, und ja, für den Arsch, ne?
Wenn man sich das anguckt, sieht das ja beim Preis-Champ.
Die Preis-Entwicklung ist ja sogar noch höher.
Kommt mal, das war am 22.01. und jetzt ist der Durchschnittspreis schon, also das war am 1.2.
War es 2.044 und hier ist der Durchschnittspreis 2.202.
Also, das kann man jetzt nicht so unbedingt immer exakt sagen, aber der Trend ist schon zu erkennen.
Ganz schön, ganz schön teuer, der Kram.
Oh, Media Markt geht jetzt auch, nice.
Ja, Expert habe ich übrigens nicht gefixt bekommen, Expert hat so komische Seiten.
Wobei, die Musiklautstärke passt, oder?
Dengel, Dengel, das geht. Excellent.
Die CPU-Preise steigen stärker als GameStop.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit GameStop jetzt aus?
Ich habe das überhaupt nicht mehr verfolgt seit dem Initialen.
Wobei, also im Vergleich zu davor ist das immer noch ganz schön viel.
Das kann sein, dass es das auf dem Handy standardmäßig hat.
Was eigentlich genau sind Skalper? Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Ich höre nur immer Skalper-Preise. Was sind Skalper?
Reseller. Ah, Reseller, okay, jetzt ergibt das Sinn.
Also sprich, das ist ein bisschen so wie früher.
Leute, die sich Konzert-Tickets vorbestellt haben und die dann auf Ebay gestellt haben.
Oder halt jetzt eine Grafikkarte zu Release kaufen oder so.
Ja, das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ey, wir haben einen auf der Arbeit gehabt.
Der hat behauptet, der hatte irgendwie mal, frag mich nicht, 15 Bitcoins oder so.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Der hat eh viel Scheiße erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist.
CheesyPro36v2, wohlgemeint V2. Wahrscheinlich, wo wir gerade beim Thema Passwort vergessen sind.
Ich glaube, das hat da auch zugeschlagen, das Thema Passwort vergessen.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Bumba-Dingsbums, acht Monate. Danke schön für den Sub. Ich hoffe, ich habe nichts übersehen.
So, ich scrolle jetzt mal kurz hier drüber.
Selbst das ist nicht so schlimm.
Ja, habe ich. Aber der Crawler ist nicht von mir, den habe ich von GitHub.
Ja, genau, so sieht es aus.
Ich speichere die Preise im Sekundentakt quasi, sobald was Neues reinkommt.
Nö, wenn du damit zufrieden bist, ist das ja gut.
Wenn man sich überlegt, das ist eigentlich ungefähr der Preis für eine 30,90.
Genau, du musst gucken, ich zeige dir das, wenn du hier auf Network Traffic gehst.
Wow, was ist das für eine Kacke hier. Geh mal fort.
Refresh, dann hast du hier irgendwo, hast du das da. Websocket, Verbindung auf CraftQL.
Darüber kommen die ganzen Daten.
Nö, das kann ruhig da bleiben.
Was? JQuery, ist alles mit JQuery gemacht.
Ich bin auch müde. Ich höre mich nicht mehr so an. Wie gesagt, ich mache heute nichts sonderlich Anspruchsvolles.
Also, ne, das ist Vue.js, das ist nicht JQuery. Und auch nicht Bootstrap, das ist Vue.js Vue.tify.
Und.NET Core im Backend. Welches OS benutzt du da?
Das hier ist gerade Windows und das da ist, das ist Banjaro mit i3-WM.
Ja, die Mods sind richtig am Qt-Chat machen. Wo ist eigentlich der Qt-Mod? Der fehlt jetzt noch.
Aber der ist wahrscheinlich im Qt-Chat zu sehr gefesselt im Discord gerade.
Kann man mit Traffic auf SSLs? Ja, kann man.
Kann man, das Ding hat eine Config, aber Traffic-Config suckt, richtig.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man sich so beschissene Config überlegen kann.
Ich mein, Apache ist schon echt übelst der Cancer. Und da hat man sich gedacht, man will Konkurrenz machen.
Richtig, so sieht's aus.
So ungefähr, ja.
So ungefähr, also der Crawler ist in Node.js, der ist nicht von mir.
Excellent.
Da können schon, so scharf drauf bin ich nicht. Wenn die Leute anfangen irgendwie da drauf zuzugreifen, dann muss ich das Passwort schützen.
Habe ich ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock drauf, dass ich jetzt 50.000 andere Seiten damit versorge.
Ist eigentlich geil. Ich crawle andere Webseiten, ich will aber selbst nicht gecrawlt werden.
So muss das sein.
Das ist schon auf GitHub, aber irgendeine uralt Version.
Gute Frage, lasst mal gucken, wie es mit Venice aussieht.
Ich mein, JackFrax hat ein Video zugemacht, die Chancen, dass ein paar Leute da sind.
Was ist heute? Sonntag, Montag? Montag, Abend ist gar nicht so gering.
Flowmania, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Bester Name, lulvgtkw, alles klar.
Oh, ein Server ist voll, aber der Server, naja gut, besser als nichts.
Bester Desktop.
Wenn einer was gegen Desktop sagt, der hat schlicht keinen Desktop Geschmack.
Natürlich.
Raw PHP und Bootstrap.
Raw PHP, Bootstrap und JQuery.
So das wie man das 2021 macht.
Was?
Hä?
Welchen Zusammenhang?
Ne, Wort, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive, der Scam Train ist am Start.
Was ist besser, Node.js oder kurz, kommt drauf an, was du machen musst.
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen, was willst du machen?
Erzähl uns mal, was du machen willst.
Was ist mit dem Azubi passiert, falls er dich erkannt hat?
Nee, der ist noch da, der müsste jetzt irgendwie im letzten Ausbildungsjahr sein oder so.
Das ist aber auch nicht der erste, der mich erkannt hat.
Mittlerweile haben es glaube ich schon drei Stück.
Ja, stimmt.
Ich komme nicht hinterher.
Ja, ich auch.
Ja, was?
Flash, Flash ist es.
Flash Leute, in Wirklichkeit ist es Flash.
Ich habe das in Flash entwickelt, damit es funktioniert, habe ich den Flash Emulator in Rust per WebAssembly Cross kompilt, dass es wieder funktioniert.
Das wäre doch mal was, was in Flash entwickeln, um es dann im Flash Emulator im Browser wieder laufen zu lassen.
Das ist ja total bescheuert.
Also, Webseiten sowie Servermanagement und Network war es eigentlich am besten dafür.
Ja, das ist jetzt ja auch sehr, sehr allgemein.
Also, für Webseiten ist keines von beiden geeignet. Für Webseiten brauchst du JavaScript, CSS und HTML.
Wenn du Webseiten backend meinst, dann dürfte das Ökosystem in Node.js auf jeden Fall ein bisschen größer sein.
Möglich ist das mit Golang aber auch.
Für Netzwerk eindeutig Go.
Und für Servermanagement keines von beiden.
Für Servermanagement würde ich entweder ganz klassisch Bash nehmen, Python oder Ansible.
Nee, keiner hat mich geleakt.
Ernsthaft? Warum das denn?
Wir haben schon eine Umfrage mal gemacht zu sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, nee, der Umfragevorschlag ist, da muss ich was machen und ich bin heute zu faul, irgendwas zu machen.
Kannst du auch machen, ja.
Warum Go für Netzwerk?
Naja, weil das gut geeignet ist für und Standard Library auch gut ist und nicht umsonst der ganze Cloud-Krempel zum größten Teil in Go ist.
Ja, nee, die haben erst mal gefragt, so es kommt Ihnen bekannt vor, da hab ich ihnen gesagt, ja ja, bin ich und sagen sie meistens, ja aber ich verrate auch nichts.
Tja, also so wirklich wahnsinnige Sachen zu machen haben wir heute nicht.
Guck mal, ich hab übrigens was witziges gefunden.
Wie ist das denn?
Warte mal, Altnet? Ja, genau, guckt euch das mal.
Wenn einer mal wieder möchte, dass es in seinem Browser aussieht wie 1995, dann kann er das Ding auch machen. Der Typ hat richtig viel Zeug drin.
Falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, schreibt es doch mal dabei.
Und was insofern ganz witzig ist, der hat auch so Sachen wie Frontpage drin.
Also wer schon immer mal wissen wollte, ich muss mal den Darkreader ausmachen, der macht es ein bisschen kaputt.
Wer schon immer mal wissen wollte, wie die Microsoft-Seite für Frontpage so irgendwie 1995, okay, Frontpage 2000 war das sogar schon.
Das ist ja dann quasi schon, das war ja dann schon 1998 oder so. Also man muss nämlich sagen, die Sachen hießen ganz schön lange 2000, noch vor 2000 und nach 2000.
Weil der Witz war, das war eine Zeit lang, da können sich die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig boomern sieht das aus.
Da können sich die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, aber es gab mal eine Zeit, da war man richtig trendy und agile, wenn man sich 2000 genannt hat im Namen.
Sonics, danke schön für Twitch Prime, da gab es so viele neue Unternehmen, die aufgemacht haben und irgendwas Blablabla 2000 im Namen drin hatten.
Und mittlerweile ist es halt oldschool, es ist 20 Jahre her, bald kommt 3000, ja okay, es ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen hin, aber...
Great Wilhelm, vier Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
FUBAR 2000, genau, Battlefield 2000, ja FUBAR 2000, den gibt es ja heute noch.
Das ist ein MP3-Player, verinner das noch jemand?
So sah das aus, FUBAR 2000, ja.
Aber das Zeug sah damals wirklich so aus, ich hab damals auch Webseiten gemacht, also es gab ja mal eine Zeit, da hat jeder irgendwie mal sich mit Webseiten basteln versucht.
Und was damals das geilste überhaupt war, wenn du GIFs drauf gemacht hast, so was hier in der Richtung, animierte GIFs.
Und hätte mir damals einer gesagt, Max im Jahr 2021 werden mehr GIFs verwendet als jemals zuvor, das hätte ich nicht geglaubt.
Sorry, GIFs natürlich, GIFs.
GIFs, GIFs, Alter.
Nils FPS, sechs Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Aber können wir uns ins Guestbook schreiben? Handle.
Da haben wir ins Guestbook gespammt, einer.
Kack, wait.
Oh, das kann man gar nicht posten ohne was, ne.
Excellent.
Kack, wait.
Ja, aber das ist auf jeden Fall cool gemacht.
Und der hat so beispielsweise auch so alte Webseiten wie Winzip.
Wo man sich immer fragt, wer hat sich eigentlich jemals die Lizenz von Winzip gekauft?
Und ja, es gab eine Zeit, da sahen Webseiten ungefähr so aus wie die Verpackung außen drauf.
Und das war damals eine richtig stylische, schöne Webseite.
Da haben wir gesagt, boah, sieht das geil aus, Alter.
Und man darf nicht vergessen, natürlich hatte man damals auch noch Windows 95 und Internet Explorer.
Und vielleicht, vielleicht noch Netscape.
Das war damals richtig futuristisch, ja.
Sogar schon Dark Theme, guckt euch das mal an.
Was sagt der Chat zu GameStop?
Der Chat, der verrät nicht, wie viel GameStop er hat.
Die halten sich alle bedeckt hier.
Moment, den Scheiß gibt es als iOS-App.
Blizzard, die alte Blizzard-Seite.
Da gibt es, mal gucken, ob es schon StarCraft gab.
Ahead of its time, ja.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich die kenne.
Ich glaube schon.
Das waren auch so die Zeiten, wo man Diablo 1 online mal gespielt hat.
Dann sah das so aus, ja.
Äußerst, ach nee, okay, da war das noch ein bisschen davor.
Das war ja noch, das war noch, das war quasi, als WarCraft gerade neu war.
Oder hatten die, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Okay, StarCraft gab es schon.
Diablo 1 gab es ja genau zu der Zeit.
Kennt jemand das Java HeapSpace Problem?
Ich glaube, das gibt, das ist eine Exception, die bei ganz vielen verschiedenen Dingern kommt.
Damals war es übrigens, ja, übrigens die Demos.
Man muss sich ja mal überlegen.
Da war damals 2, 3 MB, aber mit dem 56k Modem, da hast du auch ein paar Minuten geladen.
Nicht so ultra lang, aber war schon, war schon nice.
War schon nice, genau, da konnte man sich Battle.net runterladen.
Genau, Battle, ja, so sah das damals aus.
Ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Kann man dann auch Diablo downloaden, gut, das wird jetzt nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ja, richtige Bleeding Edge Seite, was passiert halt, wenn man das downloadet.
F.
Erst mal mit Wine starten.
Komm, das starten wir jetzt mal mit Wine und gucken, was passiert.
Hab ich das überhaupt installiert?
Okay, erst mal Wine installieren.
Twine?
Wine?
Wo ist es denn überhaupt?
Ich mach mal vorne einen Snapshot, wer weiß, was da los ist.
Okay, erst mal einen Snapshot machen.
Wo ist es denn hier, 6?
Okay, erst mal den Rechner versauen und dann starten wir das mal.
Quatsch, Netzwerk trennen.
Yolo.
Du hast meine IP-Fuck jetzt vorbei.
Jetzt ist es gelaufen, Leute.
Erst mal 800MB installieren, ja, damit ich das ausfülle.
Wahrscheinlich läuft das noch nicht mal.
Wine suckt ja auch.
So, Wine, Diablo, okay, X.
Aha.
Ja, ja, installiere alles mal.
Welche Leitung hast du?
Ich hab, lass mal überlegen, ich glaube 400MB runter und 40 oder 50, 40 glaube ich, ab.
Ja, das war...
Nee, nicht so groß wie breit.
40 ab, 400 down glaube ich.
Ja, ja, installiere mal Wine.
Wie gesagt, erst mal jetzt irgendwie 2GB runterladen, dass ich 1,5MB starten kann.
Was passiert hier gerade?
Heute passiert hier nicht allzu viel.
Wir haben uns gerade das hier angeguckt, das ist irgendein Kerl, der eine Proxy gebastelt hat.
Wo manche Seiten so aussehen wie 1998.
Ich glaube 400 runter, 50, ja, das ist Unity Media noch gewesen.
Mittlerweile wurde davon.
You need to install DOSBox.
Okay.
Dann halt DOSBox.
DOSBox.
Geht nicht.
Ich hab DOSBox, glaube ich, noch nicht verwendet.
Muss man das jetzt hier rein?
Ah, fuck DOS, Alter.
Hopp.
Das geht nicht.
Was muss ich mir anschauen?
Was G-Stalls, was hat der Link, den du schickst, jetzt genau mit dem Zahnarzt zu tun?
What?
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wie man DOSBox verwendet, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Was ich bezahle auch für die Leitung weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Also so geht es auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht, easy.
Keine Diablo Demo, die wir starten können.
Was ist denn das für ein Schwachsinn?
Oh nee, das sind die, die so super, super agile und dynamisch im Video sind.
Stimmt, ja, du hast recht.
Das hab ich schon wieder ganz vergessen.
Router selber bauen, besserer Ping und, oh nein, please.
Gut, ich mein.
Es schadet sicherlich nichts, das selbst zu machen, wenn man da scharf drauf ist.
Aber nachdem das eh noch alles durch gleiche DSL-Mode durch muss,
beziehungsweise durch das gleiche Kabel.
Okay, wir gucken uns das gleich mal an.
Da kann ich meinen Senf dazu geben.
Du musst das mounten auf DOSBox.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt absolut keinen Plus und Schimmer, wie man DOSBox verwendet.
Deswegen lasse ich das jetzt, lösche das einfach wieder.
Ich restore jetzt einfach den Snapshot.
Guck, deswegen, wenn mich einer fragt, reicht Vmware Player?
Das könnt ihr mit Vmware Player nicht machen.
Ich kann jetzt einfach wieder zurück, zack, und das ist alles weg.
Okay, Leute, wenn es sein muss, dann gucken wir das jetzt.
Aber nur weil ihr es seid, Chat, wo ist das?
Das wird Pains-Cham, ich weiß es jetzt schon.
Moment, von denen wurde mir letztens ein Video empfohlen.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, what the fuck?
Die meisten YouTuber lügen, alles klar.
Genau das habe ich letztens gesehen.
Das ist irgendwie, woran ein 40G Netzwerk daheim gebaut hat.
Das wird Pains-Cham, ich weiß es jetzt schon.
Also die Cisco-Leute sind schon mal getriggert, weil die Cisco-Leute wollen, dass es Router heißt.
Hey, was man dafür braucht, wie viel es kostet, das erfahrt ihr alles nie.
Alles, was ich euch ab diesem Punkt erzähle, ist dem Telekom Support selber nicht bekannt.
Sie geben keinen Support, sie geben gar nichts.
Ey, guck, der Telekom Support.
Ich hoffe, es ist nicht zu laut.
Ja, wenn man Videos macht, wird es einem zu warm.
Erstmal ausziehen.
In diesem Video erzähle ich euch alles, was ihr wissen müsst.
Krasse RGB-Tastatur.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich fragwürdig, warum man das machen sollte.
Ich hatte ja selbst einen OpenSense laufen und habe den ganzen Kram selbst gemacht.
Jetzt habe ich einen Mikrotik-Router da stehen, der alles für mich macht.
Aber der hört sich echt an wie mein Zahnarzt.
Leute, das sind 38 Minuten, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Selbst wenn das was gescheitert ist, das halte ich nicht aus.
Das geht nicht.
Ich kann mir das jetzt nicht... 38 Minuten, das geht nicht.
Leute, das ist nicht...
Wie sagt man so schön?
Nicht im Scope.
Das geht nicht.
Max Zahnarzt liegt.
Der hört sich echt ein bisschen an wie mein Zahnarzt.
Nee, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Oh, der Preiss-Chan hat gerade instant alles gefräst.
Habt ihr schon den geilen Filterstelz gesehen, den man jetzt machen kann?
Ja.
Exzellent.
Filterstelz kann man machen.
ESP's hassen diesen Trick, genau.
Okay, Snapshots wieder restored.
Alles gut, alles top.
So, jetzt habe ich...
Guckt euch das mal an.
Also für alle, die früher schon ein bisschen im Internet unterwegs waren, so zu 56K Modem
im ISDN zu sein.
Das ist echt...
Das ist echt nice.
Okay, da muss man aber echt hart drauf sein, wenn man sich mit dem Raspberry Pi einen
Analog-Fernseh baut.
Man kann es auch übertreiben.
Man kann es wirklich...
Was auch damals lustig war...
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Wie hieß das in...
Lycos hieß das doch damals.
Die mit dem Hund, gibt es die noch?
Kennt das noch jemand?
Lycos?
Ja, die mit dem Hund.
Das war so zur Zeit, pre-Google, eine recht beliebte Suchmaschine.
Alter Vista, Fireball.de gab es auch noch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch...
Fireball gab es da noch.
Und irgendwann kam Google und Google hat einfach besser funktioniert als alles andere und die
Leute haben instantly nur noch Google verwendet.
Aber schnell Chatscrollen.
Wie switchest du so schnell zwischen Betriebssysteme?
Ich drücke Control, Windows-Taste, rechte Pfeiltaste und linke Pfeiltaste.
Das geht folgendermaßen, du gehst hier unten drauf und dann kannst du in Windows mehrere
Desktops anlegen.
Mehrere virtuelle Desktops, wo alles virtuell ist außer der Desktop.
Und der Shortcut zum Switchen zwischen den Desktops ist Control, Windows und Pfeiltaste.
So sieht es aus.
Und dann machst du einfach eine VM auf dem zweiten Desktop auf und schon funktioniert
es.
Der Patrick hat gesagt, 19 Monate exquisite, das ist ja nicht nur Subscription, das ist
ja schon ein Stream-Subscriber hier.
Ohje, ich bin da richtig hinten dran mit dem Chat, das habe ich schon alles mal aus dem
Augenwinkel auf dem zwei Monitor gelesen.
Heutzutage ist 2000 im Namen einfach das Geburtsjahr, das stimmt.
Wobei lustig ist, ich frage mich, ob die 2000 Leute, die 2000 geboren sind, 0-0 in den Namen
machen oder...
Übrigens Leute, die 88 geboren sind, haben echt Probleme mit Username 88.
Dann kommen dann alle an, bist du etwa ein Nazi?
Nein, ich bin 88 geboren.
Gibt es genug, die damit Probleme haben?
Ja, ich bin 84 geboren, ich habe das Problem nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Wo soll ich das wissen?
Es klingt nach Stonksgedöns, das will ich nicht machen.
Keine Ahnung.
Download ICQ, gab es das hier?
ICQ nichts, aber ICQ war damals der Shit.
Das finde ich auch spannend, Archiv gucken.
Wann kommt noch eine Folge Stellanzeigen Review?
Du wirst lachen, ich habe sogar schon angefangen Sachen rauszusuchen für und ich war kurz
davor, dass ich am Sonntag schon angefangen habe aufzunehmen, also wahrscheinlich die
Woche.
Und wenn man im Jahr 69 geboren ist, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall 69 reinschreiben.
Cotton, Kori, 5 Monate, danke schön für den Zap.
Ja, so war es damals.
Schnelldurchlauf hier durch, ja habe ich tatsächlich gemacht, aber das ist schon ewig
ausgelaufen.
Also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, der Telekom Supporter habe ich den Eindruck, die geben
sich wenigstens Mühe.
Können zwar nichts machen, die geben sich wenigstens Mühe.
Ich habe zwei Bildschirme, aber ich bin heute nicht so multitaskingfähig, das beides gescheit
zu lesen.
Das kann ich nicht groß, da hat sich nichts großartiges geändert im Serverraum, außer
dass die Kiste nicht mehr in Betrieb ist.
Ich kenne meine ICQ-Nummer noch auswendig, die kann ich jetzt aber nicht sagen, weil
da findet man noch dummes Gespamme, was ich früher gemacht habe, Alter.
Ich habe so viel dummes Zeug gespammt im Internet und wenn man nach meiner ICQ-Nummer sucht,
dann findet man das.
Wenn es dir gefällt, ist es immer top, heute ist aber nicht so viel Technik-Gestreme angesagt.
Für mich sind alle Leute, die nach 1990 geboren sind, jung, das habe ich mir irgendwann mal
gemerkt.
Dabei sind die halt auch schon dreißig.
Also das ist ja wirklich, 2002 ist ja mal ein richtig summer.
Was ist mit dem Server denn, wieso, geht es nicht mehr?
Ach, mit meinem Server, also der ist einfach nur noch vorhanden.
Also den hier meine ich, den da, der fette, der ist einfach nur noch da, der macht nichts
mehr.
Der war zu oversized, mein Server, ich habe das schon mal, ich habe da noch schon mal
ein Video zu aufgenommen.
2013, da bin ich gerade frisch eingezogen, da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern,
was hatte ich denn da drinnen?
Ah, das ist die alte Kiste, das ist die, wo ich letztens gemeint habe, da hatte ich diese
sieben oder acht oder sechs, sieben, acht, frage mich nicht, zwei Terabyte Platten im
Raid 6 drin und da habe ich jedes Mal gezittert, dass der Scheiß wieder hochkommt, total oversized
für meine Verhältnisse.
Da hatte ich doch die alte USB, wobei ich ja sagen muss, die alte APC-USB ist besser
gewesen als diese neue Crap-USB, die ich gekauft habe, von der ich eigentlich dachte, dass
die gut ist, wo das einzige in meinem Rack je die USB war, die verreckt ist.
Alles Telekom-Telefon, oh, das ist noch eine ISDN-Telefonanlage, ok, das war 2013, das
ist noch gar nicht so lange her, Leute, ISDN-Telefonanlage.
Hast du mittlerweile eine Capture Card zurück, du meinst vom M-Core, ja, ich glaube schon,
die hatte ich glaube ich schon das letzte Mal zurück, ich bin mir aber gar nicht, ich
bin mir aber nicht wirklich sicher, ob ich die zurückgekriegt habe, ich glaube aber
schon.
So, Max, zeigst du da auch noch mal irgendwas Interessantes, da noch irgendwas Interessantes
zu sehen, Max, da sieht man, das ist ja richtig oldschool DSL noch mit Splitter und NTBA,
das gibt's heute, das braucht man heute gar nicht mehr, sag mal so, das ist heute eigentlich
überflüssig.
Mach mal Gartenstelz, ich hab Schneestelz gemacht vorletzten Samstag, hab ich noch
mal hochgeladen, ja, und das hier ist analogisches Telefon, das war 2013, das kommt mir noch
gar nicht so lange vor, ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass ich 2013 noch ISDN und Splitter
und analogisches Geschiss am Start hatte, tja, guck mal, das alte Speedport unten in
der Ecke, ich glaube das habe ich immer noch, billigster Tepelling-Switch, ne, noch kein
Tepelling-Switch, high quality Tepelling-Switch, aber das Kabelmanagement ist schon poggers,
muss man sagen.
Da hab ich den Kabelkanal gezeigt, ok, da, warum hat das eigentlich RGB, du hattest aber
auch schon, ich glaube, das war, da hatte ich beides, da hatte ich Unity Media und Telekom
zusammen noch.
Tja, kann ich, konnte ich mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, dass ich da mal ein Video zugemacht
hab, Sachen gibt's.
Hast du mal was für das OpenWrt gemacht, ne, kommt da ein TS5-Server, ich glaube nicht,
das TS5, also es gibt zwei Sorten von Leuten, die, die mittlerweile schon auf Discord umgestiegen
sind und die, die noch für immer TS3 oder teilweise sogar TS2-Server betreiben werden,
die werden gar kein TS5 installieren, das coole an Teamspeak ist halt, dass du selbst hausen
kannst im Vergleich zu Discord.
Was sind eigentlich deine Arbeitszeiten, arbeitest du normal 18 Stunden, ja, also ich arbeite,
also ich arbeite von Dienstags bis Freitags vier Tage die Woche, also 7,5 Stunden und ich
hab keine Bereitschaft mehr, also ich früher mal hab ich mittlerweile schon lange nicht
mehr.
Nice, komm mal, hast du probiert zu flaschen oder willst du nicht flaschen?
Ja, ne, genau, die gehen nämlich dann mal richtig, das ist das, wo der Typ das Video
aufgemacht, wie man aufschreiben muss, wie man aufschrauben muss, ne, haben wir noch
nicht gemacht, wir haben uns aber ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben, bzw. der mk hat Sachen
aufgeschrieben, ich hab ein paar Sachen zu kommentiert, wisst ihr, ich bin immer faul,
was das angeht.
Nice, ich hab mittlerweile abgebaut, ne, also ich hab ja von diesem Ultra Setup, was ich
immer am Start hatte mit 4HE-Kiste, 10G-Switch und sonst was, das ist jetzt alles weg, weil
das Ding war ein riesen Single-Point-of-Failure, wenn das ausgefallen wäre, dann ginge noch
nicht mal meine Rolle in den Hoch, geschweige denn das Internet, halt echt Müll, deswegen
hab ich das jetzt ein bisschen aufgeteilt, da hab ich einen Mikrotik-Router für Routing-Zeug,
unterschiedliche Access-Points, für Fernsehgedöns drüben was, ne extra Nass und ein paar Raspberries
verteilt, so dass es viel besser, wenn da mal eins kaputt geht, geht wegen so nur eine
Sache kaputt, das war eigentlich so sinnvoll, aber ich mein, das war ne coole Geschichte,
ja.
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Glaub nicht, ne?
Ja, die bleiben manchmal an ganz merkwürdigen Stellen hängen, so ein Strap-Saw-Roboter.
Das mal ge-edit, kann ich das aufmachen, ich klicke immer ungern Sachen so an im Stream,
wartet mal.
Ah cool, nice.
Woop, Woop-Rainbow, quasi das richtige Woop-RGB, Alter, ok, das adden wir gleich mal.
Habt ihr euch gesehen, wir haben jetzt, aber auch so schon Woop-RGB, wobei eigentlich Woop-RGB
nicht wirklich RGB ist, sondern eigentlich müsste das eher Woop-Funny sein oder sowas,
oder Woop-Pride oder irgendwas, ne, wenn ich das Woop-Pride nenne, dann stören sich wieder
Leute dran, dass der eine Klauenase auf hat und heute sind die Leute so schnell dabei
Trigger zu sein, so nach dem Motto, hast du was gegen Schwule, Max, warum hat der Pride
Keks eine Klauenase auf, was soll das hier anzeigen, gehst du raus, dann sind Leute Ultratrigger,
das geht heute total schnell.
Ich hab mich da früher auch übelst triggern lassen immer, ne, ich weiß noch, es hat mal
irgendwie einer, also mit dem Fabian noch Videos gemacht, das war bei irgendeinem Typ,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie weit, das war, ich glaub Rampage Striker oder so hieß der, das
war irgendein Kollege vom Danny Burnage damals glaube, der hat übelst, übelst gegen Schwule
rumgehated und da hab ich ihn damals gleich gebannt, heute hätt ich mich von sowas alles
gar nicht mehr triggern lassen, hätt ich mir gedacht, die Leute sollen labern und gut
ist, das, wenn ich wüsste, wie das funktioniert, wenn ich wüsste, wie das funktioniert, warte
mal, wie geht das, wie kann man Leute VIP machen, slash VIP, na jetzt, was macht denn VIP Status
überhaupt, nichts, ne, Shane, ja super, jetzt kann ich da Namen nicht richtig eingeben,
oh shit, probieren wir mal was aus, exquisite, core, ich hab einen VIP Benutzer,
ja, jetzt musst du natürlich auch weiter Emotes machen, das ist nicht, das ist keine
One-Way-Geschichte, also jetzt bist du, jetzt hast du mitgehangen, mitgefangen, ne, aber
der ist nice, ja, tja, wie gesagt Leute, ich hab heute absolut nichts vorbereitet, weil
das verbackt ist, die Expert-Seite, die ist komisch aufgebaut, ich hab's noch nicht gecheckt,
was man da fixen muss, dass es das nicht mehr findet, was macht eigentlich Nextcloud so,
ich mag Nextcloud nicht, das wisst ihr, aber haben die mal, haben die neue Version mal
wieder rausgebracht, die vielleicht weniger schlecht ist, so 21 oder so, was ist die letzte
Version Nextcloud, was machen die, fuck du, was hast du gegen Nextcloud, dass es einfach
an allen Stellen, an allen Ecken und Enden unfertiger Kram ist, äh, gibt nix neues,
zum Glück, wie das mit kaufen, ey, ohne Scheiß, ich würd's wahrscheinlich sogar machen, aber
ich hab keinerlei Broker-Apps oder sowas, Sie fallen mal getestet, ne, OnClone hat alles,
echt, echt, haben die neue Version, zeig mal hier, OnClone, machen die jetzt Konkurrenz,
die doch immer noch genauso aus, oder, Preise, echt, haben die was neues gebaut, das haben
wir schon geguckt, das Video, äh, haben die vielleicht ein paar irgendwie Bildchen, wo
man das jetzt sieht, oder ne Demo, oder so, Demo, Demo, ey, achso, das ist mein Dark Seed,
was rum, ich bin blind, wie wär's mal mit ein paar Bildern, Leute, wisst ihr, ich versteh
nicht, warum das immer noch so viele, äh, Äh, Hersteller verkacken, mach doch einfach
Bilder auf die Startseite, wo ist das Problem, news, aha, hm, okay, das sieht jetzt eher
so aus, als brauchen die noch ein bisschen, bis da was brauchbares rauskommt, weil, hier
ist die Demo, Demo, Demo, das sieht genauso kacke aus, wie früher, in welchem IT-Job
muss man null programmieren, Druckerpatronentauscher, das sieht ja noch genauso, okay, das ist noch
der gleiche Crap, wie vorher, überhaupt kein Unterschied, ne, aber ganz ehrlich, Next
Cloud ist übelste, also Next Cloud, ich mag das Zeug überhaupt nicht, ich verwende es
jetzt halt für nen File Sync, aber da will ich was anderes nehmen, weil, also ich verwende
im Prinzip eh nur die Basics davon, ich verwende ein bisschen File Sync und den Kalender und
die Kontakte, aber ganz im Ernst, das ist so ein Haufen unfertiger Kram, die haben es
bis zur letzten Version noch nicht mal geschafft, dass man ihn in der Notiz-App suchen konnte,
seit 5 Jahren oder so, ja, habe ich, deswegen braucht der auch so viel Leistung, weil der
190 Chromium Instanzen Auffahrt im Hintergrund, ist ein VPN hinter, ja klar, oder meinst du
von außen nach innen, dann musst du ein paar Vorkehrungen treffen, ja, am Preis-Champ kann
man suchen, ja, aber nicht wirklich viel, Moin, hast du ein paar Tipps für ein Bewerbungsgespräch
bei Siemens als Werkstudent, ehrlich gesagt nicht, da war ich noch nie in der Situation,
dass ich da mich als Werkstudent irgendwo bewerben müsste, was sicherlich nicht verkehrt
ist, wenn man nen GitHub Repo hat, wo man ein bisschen was zeigen kann, also für die
Bewerbung jetzt, für das Bewerbungsgespräch eher nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung, nee, ja,
das liegt daran, weil es auch Nextcloud ist, das war ja im Prinzip alles mal Owncloud früher,
genauso sieht es aus, Nextcloud, ja, genauso fühlt sich auch Nextcloud an und die machen
immer mehr Kram dabei, anstatt mal ihre eigentliche Software zu fixen, by the way, wie hast du
eigentlich geschafft bei Semper Video gebannt zu werden, also ich hab Home Assistant, das
hab ich ja schon ein paar mal gezeigt hier auch, ne, also, und halt einen, mindestens
einen Funkstandort, wo man sich ein bisschen drauf festlegen kann, ich mein, das muss
ja nicht jeder so bescheuert machen wie ich, ich hab ZigBee, Z-Wave und WLAN und Bluetooth,
ich hab alles, was aber nicht so sinnvoll ist, aber dafür kann ich die billigen Geräte
kaufen, nee, ich wollt keine Fake-Bewertung machen, ich wollt echte Bewertung machen,
das hier, ach so, ja, das haben wir schon mal geguckt, das Video, how to burn money in
the cloud, das ist die Endlosschleife in the cloud machen, also, das ist tatsächlich
eine gute Frage, also wenn man sich von innen nach draußen connecten will, ist das natürlich
kein Problem mit DS Lite, was mit DS Lite schwierig ist, wenn man sich von außen nach
innen connecten will, also sprich, sag mal, von unterwegs zu sich heim, da gibt's auch
Möglichkeiten, das einfachste ist Public Server, sich zu mieten in ganz billigen 2,90 Euro
im Monat und dann irgendwie SSH Tunnel mit portweiter Leitung oder sowas, das ist so
ziemlich das einfachste was man machen kann, oder von dort halt einen Tunnel hinbauen und
dann über diesen, über die Public IP von dem Server über den Tunnel zum eigenen Router
oder sowas, also, das geht, das geht, auf jeden Fall ist es unnötig kompliziert mit
DS Lite, aha, war das dieser ultramega teurer Fernseher, das weiß ich nicht, also, das
ist, das ist der Fuchs aus Sonic, aber ich glaube, du meinst eher das Linux, ja, das
ist eine super Geschichte, das gute ist, mein Home Assistant ist von außen nicht erreichbar
und macht eh nur intern im Netz was, das heißt, ich hab da wenige Probleme mit, also, was
du brauchst ist, du brauchst irgendwo, also, wenn du über IPv6 rein willst, falls du die
Möglichkeit hast, über IPv6 reinzugehen, ist es total einfach, weil da kannst du einfach
eine IPv6 Adresse nehmen, da hast du genug bei DS Lite und alles ist gut, also, wenn
du dich über IPv6 connecten kannst, ist alles gut, sollte das nicht gehen, weil du bei O2
bist und die immer noch kein IPv6 im Mobile haben, dann musst du dir irgendwo eine Public
IP herkriegen, wo du einen Tunnel aufbauen kannst von innen nach außen, wo du dann quasi
auf die Public IP vom Server gehst und über diesen vorher aufgebauten Tunnel wieder zurück
zu dir an den Router, wo du dann das VPR nach innen aufbaust, ist ein bisschen komplizierter,
aber am aller einfachsten ist es über IPv6, das da, das Half Life da unten, das ist ein
bisschen, das ist das Half Life eigentlich offensichtlicher, das ist das Half Life, ja.
Was ist, eindeutig VDSL, VDSL, wenn da alles richtig eingestellt ist, ist absolut top,
das Problem ist bei DS Lite ja auch gar nicht so sehr, dass das jetzt ultra-störanfällig
wäre, sondern dass das von Haus aus ein paar Probleme hat und das größte Problem an DS
Lite ist erstmal, du kannst keine Ports weiter leiten und das zweite Problem ist, du teilst
dir mit ganz vielen Leuten eine Ausgangs-IP, das heißt, wenn da einer Scheiße baut, bist
du auch geblockt.
Die Ausgangspunkte bei DS Lite heißen übrigens After, weil man da rüber rausgeht, nee, die
heißen, deswegen eine Abkürzung für irgendwas.
Hast du schon mal VPM mit IPv6 eingerichtet, nö, aber ich hab schon Beispiele gesehen
für Konfig von OpenVP und WireGuard, das ist gar kein Akt.
Sinn hinter was?
Dual Monitor, also ich hab auch einen ganz normalen 16 zu 9 Monitor, 240Hz und neben
dran hab ich noch einen anderen stehen, so einen kalibrierten ISO, falls ich mal wirklich
irgendwas ganz exakt mir angucken muss, aber auch beides, 16 zu 9, zwei Monitore sind besser.
Wie viel Zoll, ich glaub 24 und 23 oder 2 mal 24, ist es auf jeden Fall kaum ein Unterschied
dazwischen.
Das würde funktionieren, ich verwende aber kein Apple HomeKit, das würde aber funktionieren.
Half Life 3 liegt bei mir in der Taskleiste, fuck Leute, jetzt ist es raus.
Jetzt scheiße, jetzt ist es vorbei, CacWaite und wenn ihr nicht aufpasst, dann kommt da
gleich, dann ist es vorbei, geht lieber in Deckung.
Ich hab mal Zweifel, dass ob uns jemals IPv4 Adressen ausgehen werden, es ist jetzt nicht
mehr so easy, dass ich sagen kann, hallo ich bin Provider, möcht neuen 8er Block oder
so was, aber ob die uns wirklich je ausgehen werden, weiß ich nicht.
Drei Curve, also das wäre mir ehrlich gesagt fast ein bisschen viel, wir haben einen Curve
Monitor auf der Arbeit, einen ziemlich breiten halt, einen zweiten davon bräuchte ich gar
nicht, ne hab ich doch nicht, da lieg ich zu viel, wenn ich das zeige, ja ist alles
Geschmackssache.
Ich sitz relativ nah vor dem Monitor, da brauch ich nicht so einen großen, guck mal, der
Witz ist, ich sitz relativ nah vor dem Monitor, ne, aber mein YouTube ist eingestellt auf
was weiß ich, 150% oder so, ist halt Boomer Augen, ja machst du nix, ach da gibt's doch
eh nix, Steam Sale ist doch eh immer nur Crap, was aber irgendwie ein bisschen daran liegt,
dass es zum größten Teil auch nur Crap gibt, ey wir haben schon, ich kann mich noch dran
erinnern, wir haben mal ein YouTube Video geguckt, der Typ hatte seine, der hatte eine eigene
REC Klimaanlage und sowas gebaut mit eigenen Rohren und sonst was, manche übertreiben
es in der Heimausstattung komplett, wobei ich mich halt immer frage, was der Scheiß
halt an Strom kostet, das ist doch überhaupt nicht wert, ich bastel auch immer gerne,
ups, ich bastel ja auch immer gerne, ne, das wisst ihr ja, aber es hat auch keinen Sinn,
wenn ich dann irgendwie 500€ Stromkosten hab oder so, im Monat oder was auch immer,
ich brauch noch mehr, der Typ, er zum Beispiel, der Typ mit den drei Playcentern, also, immer
ich mein, es ist cool, aber letztendlich hat man sich da irgendwann auch mal dran satt
geguckt und dann bleibt ja nur noch das übrig, was praktisch ist und so viel praktisches
gibt es da dran, ich ne, so, ich muss mal kurz eine Runde den Chat in den Hacker Modus
versetzen, so, only big brain Themen jetzt, ne, für big brain Themen bin ich heute eh
nicht mehr empfänglich, oh ne, ich bin heute so kaputt, ich kann echt nichts Sinnvolles
mehr machen, der Wahnsinn, wie grad 280 Leute da sind, die mir einfach beim Nichts machen
zugucken, aber schön, dass ihr alle am Start seid, find ich gut, ich hatte ja die Hoffnung
Leute, ganz ehrlich, ich hatte die Hoffnung letztes Jahr, dass ich mir dieses, Anfang
dieses Jahres noch einen Rechner bauen kann, aber das ist ja, dass ich die Preise anguckte,
also ich könnte, aber ich sehe es nicht ein, 2000, Alter, 2500, aber ja, übrigens habt
ihr diese, diese super Schnäppchen, diese super Schnäppchen PS5 gesehen, also ich finde
auch für den Preis, ne, für den Preis kann man keine kostenlose Lieferung erwarten, also
ich finde, das ist so knapp kalkuliert, da kann man schon noch mal 11,02 Euro draufhauen,
bestimmt auch noch China Seller oder so, wie sah das eigentlich traffic-mäßig, ach vollkommen
in Ordnung, generell muss man sagen, ey Leute, der Preis-Champ ist echt high performance,
ne, also geht so, aber selbst nach dem Video, da hatte ich teilweise 1000, noch was Leute
gleichzeitig drauf, und das ging nicht über 30% CPU-Last von einem der 16 Kerne, aber
guckt euch mal die Preise an, Alter, das kann euch jetzt nicht, das kann euch wirklich
nicht in den Ernst sein, wir testen noch ein paar andere Hosts in den nächsten Tagen,
aber heute kriege ich geistig nichts mehr auf die Reihe, deine Grafika hat jetzt vor
einer Woche kaputt gegangen, das ist schlecht, wann Preis-Champ-Native Dark Mode, wie jetzt,
ist G-Bait, das Ding hat doch Dark Mode, guck, musst du einfach auf den Kick-Click, da kannst
du zwischen Dark und Light umschalten, wieso ist Light Mode Default eingestellt, ganz einfach,
weil die ganzen Noobs mit Dark Mode nichts anfangen können, geht mal, macht, macht,
macht mal den Spaß, geht, lauft mal durch eure Personal-Abteilung und guckt, ob da
einer Dark Seam hat, und dann seht ihr, die Noobs haben Light Seam, das ist einfach so,
die meisten Leute checken das noch nicht einmal, dass es das überhaupt gibt, also im Homeoffice,
ja stimmt, ihr könnt nicht durch die, stimmt, das geht ja grad nicht, aber ihr wisst, was
ich meine, ja, ja, die sind aber echt immer ganz dicht, oh, das ist, das ist Pock, das
ist Pock, nicht schlecht, ich will ja immer noch eine 3090 für einen neuen Rechner haben,
aber ich sehe es nicht, einen 2300 Euro für auszugeben, ja, das habe ich mir auch schon
überlegt, ob ich das noch einbaue, dass das Ding immer quasi nach System-Settings geht,
ich hoffe, es hat auch was gebracht, die Battlefield-Pros haben einen Plaufilter, ja, ne, das Problem
ist, es fragen ja auch viele Leute, ob man hier nicht irgendwie Custom-Items tracken kann,
das Problem ist, also erstens müsste ich da in irgendeiner Art und Weise so ein Login-Account-System
machen, dass die Leute sich verifizieren müssen oder irgendwie, das ist schon mal kacke und
außerdem wäre das Ding instant überlastet, wenn da jetzt auf einmal die Leute noch 50.000
neue Dinge rein machen, das klappt nicht, der ist ja jetzt schon teilweise alles zusammen,
braucht ja an die 12 CPU-Cores zu Spitzenlastzeiten, das ist nicht sonderlich effizient, der hat
auch 190 Chromium-Taps offen, dass der aktualisiert, also da kannst du nichts mehr dazu machen,
das scale nicht richtig gut, ja, wobei doch, das scale ziemlich gut, aber das braucht halt
Ressourcen ohne Ende, ich hab schon neue Artikel, ich hab doch nicht Switch reingemacht, aber
da hab ich aktuell nur Amazon verlinkt drinne, da ist, da ist Switch und Switch Lite verfügbar,
aber das hab ich noch nicht verknüpft richtig, sammelst du eigentlich auch Stats wie zum
Beispiel die Alerts, was, hä, also ich sammel keine Statistiken von Leuten, nee, also sprich
ich hab keine Ahnung wie viele Leute Alerts aktiviert haben, das einzige was ich sammel
sind halt Zugriffe, aber da muss ja nix tracken für, deswegen brauch ich auch kein Cookie
oder DSGVO Hinweis, also das einzige was ich speichere ist ob man Darkseam oder Lightseam
eingestellt hat, aber das speichere ich auch nur lokal und schick mir die Informationen
nicht, also insofern ist das okay, ansonsten brauch ich, ich weiß die Webseite ist nicht
wirklich, ähm, warum hat das hier in unter ananas gone die anderen Dinger nicht, was
ist hier los, guck dir mal, das hat nen Strich unten drunter und das net, kick wait, ach
ja es gibt jetzt übrigens nen Changelog, guck mal, könnt ihr euch nen Changelog angucken
von heute, Massive Changelog, man kann jetzt Kategorie filtern, ja, Paulgas, die Alerts,
nein, nein, nein, die Alerts sind rein frontend, deswegen geht der Scheiß ja auf iOS auch nicht,
weil iOS keine Browser Notifications erlaubt, gibt es ein Gästebuch, oh nee das mach ich
nicht, sobald Leute online Sachen schreiben können ist das voll mit Dickpicks oder irgendwie
anderem Schwachsinn, das kannst du, ich lass nirgends wo einmal was uploaden, ne, keine
Chance, das ist alles, nee das kannst du komplett knicken, das mach ich nicht, das kannst du
vergessen, ich kann damit ins Bett gehen, überhaupt kein Problem, es gibt ne neue Variante
wie man bei iOS Notifications verschicken kann, hab ich gelernt, das geht über Wallet,
das geht aber auch nur wenn die Leute irgendeinen Code scannen oder sowas und es kostet Geld,
total hängen geblieben, ey, kann Apple nicht einfach Native oder, nee, was ist Native,
ganz normal die Browser Notification API unterstützen, so wie das Android kann und so ziemlich alles
andere auch, bloß Apple nicht, aber der Browser weiß doch nicht wie die aktuellen Preise sind
wenn der Browser die Seite nicht auflädt, deswegen, gut, du kannst die Seite aufmachen
und den Browser minimieren oder du kannst zu deinem Homescreen adden und dort als PWA
starten, was du nicht machen darfst ist die App in irgendeiner Weise zu killen oder komplett
auszumachen, dann kriegst du auch keine Notifications mehr, du kannst das minimieren, du kannst den
Browser zumachen, aber du darfst nicht irgendwie, also bei Android auf den Homescreen gehen
oder so, aber du darfst nicht den Browser killen, dann kriegst du keine Notifications
mehr, aber wenn du es auf den Homescreen geadded hast, dann läuft es eher als eigene Anwendung,
weißt du, bei Apple ist es so, wenn du diese Wallet Push Sachen machen musst und das ist
gar nicht mal billig, ne, Apple Wallet Push Signal Lies hatten das, guckt euch mal an
was das kostet, Preise, ja 30 Euro im Monat für 2500 Empfänger, also das bezahle ich
nicht und 2500 Empfänger kriege ich sicherlich gut hin, das Ding hat 15.000 Seitenaufrufe
am Tag gerade, oben stand dick kostenlos, ja aber keine Wallet Notifications, die Seite
sieht nur so aus, weil ich Dark Mode an hab, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das gerecht ist,
aber kostenlos ist nur Web Push und App Push und du brauchst Wallet Push, das gibt's nur
für Premium und die Leute müssen irgendwas machen, ich hab mir aber was anderes überlegt,
was man auch machen könnte, das könnten wir wirklich in einem nächsten Stream, ich könnte
einen Telegram, ich könnte einen Telegram Bot machen, dann müsste man das irgendwie
so machen, dann klickt man hier drauf und dann mach ich einen extra Popup für Telegram
Notifications und dann müssten die Leute halt ihre Telegram, frag mich nicht, Group
ID oder was man da zum identifizieren braucht hinterlegen und dann kriegt man da auch Notifications,
ja was denn sonst, WhatsApp geht nicht, Signal hat glaub ich auch eine AP, kannst du noch
mal den Dark Mode addon zeigen, was da, der Dark Reader, Discord Notifications gehen auch,
wobei ich da das irgendwie identifizieren müsste und ich glaub das ist nicht so einfach,
das ist glaub ich nicht so einfach mit Discord Notifications dann, das weiß ich nicht wie
das funktioniert, das müsste man irgendwie schauen, weil ich hab ja keine Login Systeme
oder sonst was, das heißt man kann sich da auch nicht mit Discord irgendwie identifizieren,
einfach Webhook Support, ne ich brauch ja irgendwas, was ein gewisses Secret dabei hat,
was nur derjenige haben kann, der weiß was er machen will, also zum Beispiel eine geheime
Group ID, dann weiß ich der, der die Group ID hat, der wills auch haben und bei Webhooks
ist es halt so ein Ding, da kannst du irgendeine beliebige Seite eintragen und die spam ich
dann voll ob, wo die das will oder nicht und Discord ist auch nicht so einfach, also wie
gesagt das einfachste wäre, wenn Apple einfach ordentlich Notifications unterstützt, dann
könnte man das nämlich einfach verwenden, aber Apple sagt dazu einfach nur und macht
es nicht, oh Leute ich bin heute echt müde, das ist der Wahnsinn, ich bin zu nichts mehr
in der Lage irgendwas großartig zu machen, gibt es eigentlich aktuelle Linux Distros,
wo man sich, wo es sich mal lohnt wieder anzugucken, die Seite sieht, alter sieht die Seite scheiße
aus, fällt mir jedes mal auf, diese Seite sieht so dermaßen schlecht aus, ist da noch
keiner auf die Idee gekommen von den geilen Linux Hackern, das mal irgendwie halbwegs zeitgemäß
zu machen, ich mein das muss keine Android Native Style Material Design App oder so werden,
aber irgendwas was nicht ganz so nach 1995 aussieht vielleicht, im Zweifelsfall mit Wordpress
oder so, Distrochamp als nächstes, MX, warum ist MX Linux eigentlich so beliebt, das hat
mir überhaupt nicht gefallen, Manjaro hat es verdient, Mint ist dabei, Pop OS, ja okay
die üblichen, was ist denn Endeavor OS schon wieder für Gedöns, ah Arch, Exzellent, ne
gibt nichts spannendes Neues, Champ OS zu Weihnachten, ja wir machen einfach alles neu,
als nächstes gibt es die Champ Cloud, champ.cloud, da mach ich meinen eigenen Cloud Service nur
um den Preischamp zu hausten, so machen wir das, Cloudchamp, kennste Garuda, ne sagt mir
nichts, wie läuft der Preischamp, ziemlich geschmeidig, kaum CPU Last, obwohl es ordentlich
Benutzer drauf hat, genau Champ VPN machen wir auch noch, so siehts aus, Champ VPN kommt
auch noch dabei, Telechamp, Telechamp wir machen alles, wir verchampen alles, wir machen
alles neu selbst, Champ Cloud, Champ Datacenter alles, Champ Hentai, alles, Champ Hub, Internet
of Champs, stimmt mein Serverraum ist wohl leer, ernsthaft die haben sowas, wir machen
einen ICQ Bot, das hat die Welt gebraucht, endlich, gehört das nicht irgendwelchen Russen
mittlerweile, ICQ, ICQ.ru, ICQ Champ, naja gut, wer wirds verkraften, das ist ein ziemlich
geiler VPN Name, Impognito, das ist echt geil, würd ich sofort so nennen, Impognito VPN Service,
der eigene Programmiersprache brauchen wir auch noch, Leute ich hab keine Ahnung mehr,
was ich im Stream machen soll, ich bin voll planlos heute, ich bin einfach on gekommen
und ich bin übelst im Arsch, krieg nix mehr zustande heute, was ist das für ein komisches,
das ASCII-Quarium, das ist das erste was man sich unter Lelungs installieren muss, planlos
mit 203 Zuschauern, naja, also wenn man planlos mit 203 Zuschauern Boop-Cam machen kann,
kann man auch planlos mit 203 Zuschauern ASCII-Quarium angucken, wenn ich nochmal 20 wäre Leute,
wenn ich nochmal 20 wäre, dann würd ich einfach Boop-Cam, Boop-Cam Streamer werden, easy money,
genau, so siehts aus, das gabs da noch nicht, Kio-Kont, das ist ne gute Idee, soll ich jetzt
auch machen, ich soll jetzt einfach ins Pen gehen, ich bin so im Arsch, hast du deinen
Pi in einem KVM-Switch umgebaut, nö, ich hab nen richtigen KVM-Switch, den ich lustigerweise
nichts verwende, aber ich hab nen KVM-Switch, ich hab mal bei eBay nen Billing gekauft, eines
der wenigen Einkäufe der letzten Jahre, die ich auf eBay gemacht hab, wieso klappt bei
mir die Webseite Local Horse 5002 nicht, ja, das war ganz schlechter Chebat-Versuch, wobei
ich weiß es gibt Leute, die checken es wirklich nicht, aber nicht hier, hier ist die Chance
eines Chebates deutlich zu hoch bei solchen Fragen, Boot-Camp bräuchten wir auch noch
Leute, Boot-Camp, das wird unser eigener Bootloader, was denkst du über die Manifest V3-Extension,
keine Ahnung, sagt mir Ines mit zu Big Plane, sagt mir gar nichts, high IQ Chat, so ist es,
es war ein Witz, da wär ich ja überhaupt nicht drauf gekommen, was ist die Manifest
V3-Extension, ich hab keine Ahnung, irgendwas für Chrome Addons oder so, ich hab keinen
Schimmer, ich weiß es nicht, kenne auch nicht jeden Kram, Leute, warum hab ich 300 Zuschauer,
können wir das nicht bei Streams haben, wo ich, wobei in letzter Zeit haben wir doch
tatsächlich relativ viele Zuschauer, ich wollte gerade sagen, können wir das nicht
standardmäßig in Streams haben, wo ich was mache, anstatt einfach nur da sitze und nichts
mache, hier können 18 Monate, meine Güte hier, danke schön für den Sub, was ist das,
morgen Mathe 3 Prüfung, easy, easy as fuck, einfach hin Big Plane einschalten, Prüfung
schreiben, Big Plane ausschalten, sparen fürs nächste Mal, ok, dann gibt es vielleicht
doch wieder einen Grund, Firefox zu verwenden, Chrome Manifest V3, was gibt es dazu, es gibt
kein Extension Problem, das ist ja das Problem, deswegen ärgert es mich ja auch so besonders,
dass Firefox sich seit Jahren selbst kaputt macht, weil sobald Google keine halbwegs ernst
zu nehmende Alternative mehr hat, dann machen die halt so eine Scheiße wie, wir schränken
jetzt einfach AdBlock ein, ich mein, guckt euch mal an, wie das unter iOS ist mit AdBlocks,
du kannst zwar den AdBlocker installieren, den hast du aber nur in Safari, den hast du
in keiner anderen App und wenn es nach Google geht, ist Werbung natürlich das, womit sie
Big Stonks machen, also, ganz so abwegig ist das nicht, seid ihr auch, seid ihr auch
Cloud-Native und könnt gut horizontal skalieren und ich hoffe ihr erfolgt auch Best Practices
und macht regelmäßig Crumbs, Sprints und habt ein Kanber an Bord, Google Stadia ist
angeblich RIP, das glaube ich nicht, ich mein, es war von Anfang an RIP, aber dass sie das
einstellen, glaube ich nicht, Moment, KekWaite, KekWaite, äh ja, es war halt von Anfang an
Scheiße, aber wohlgemerkt, das heißt ja nicht, dass Stadia eingestellt wurde, aber wenn
ihr die First Party Studios eingestellt werdet, das sagt schon einiges, ja, ja, ja, ja, Accept.
Leute, Leute, soll ich euch mal eine Sache sagen, wo ich als erstes an Stadia, oder
ich frage mal, Chat, was meint ihr, was das erste ist, woran ich denke, wenn ich Stadia
höre, von den Marketingaussagen, von den Marketingaussagen, Bitconnect, nein, Negative
Latenz, korrekt, Negative Latenz, genau daran denke ich als erstes, Negative Latency, was
für dumm Schwätzer, Alter, okay, also, was haben sie denn hier, ähm, ja, ja, Revolutionize,
ich hab von Anfang an gesagt, mega Crap, wobei ich mir auch unschlüssig war, wie viele
Kacknoobs darauf aufspringen, aber es ist einfach so, und ich weiß nicht, warum sich
das die Google Big Stonks Leute nicht gedacht haben, die, die wirklich PC-Spiele spielen
oder competitive oder interessiert am PC sind, die wollen nicht keinen PC, die wollen
ihren PC haben daheim, und die wollen auch keine Kompromisse eingehen, ich hab's eh
nicht verstanden, aber zum Glück hat die Telekom Agenta Gaming, die können jetzt die
Weltherrschaft an sich reißen, wenn Stadia weg ist, so, Moment, was, und das hab ich
jetzt gecheckt, was, Game Making Business, okay, also die Plattform direkt zu Publisher
Stadia Pro, aha, was haben die Google Game Studios eigentlich gemacht, was, was, was
haben die Google Game Studios eigentlich entwickelt, was, was haben die denn so gemacht, das ist
ja zu fürchten, aus das Bild, ja, ja, ich hab keine Ahnung, was die so gemacht haben,
Google Studio, was, Montreal haben die gesagt, Google Game Studio, was haben die so gemacht,
man weiß es nicht, nix, also die haben keine Games gemacht, okay, das hat sich ja richtig
gelohnt, ja, ja, bla, bla, bla, bla, das hat ja nicht funktioniert, also irgendwie Konkurrenz
zu Konsolen zu machen hat nix, hat überhaupt nicht getan, ich muss euch mal ehrlich sagen,
ich glaube, Xbox Series S und X, warum sind die Dinger eigentlich so scheiße benannt
von Microsoft wieder, und PS5, das ist für mich die mit Abstand langweiligste Konsolengeneration
aller Zeiten, ich fand die letzte schon langweilig zu Release, aber die aktuelle ist mega langweilig,
es gibt ja nix für, diesmal ist die Hardware wenigstens besser als das letzte Mal, Xbox
One und PS4 hat am Anfang absolut Crap Hardware, also sie mussten ja dieses Zwischen Release
machen, aber die jetzige hat wenigstens, verglichen zu damals, zu dem, was damals aktuell war,
hat jetzt wenigstens ein bisschen bessere Hardware, aber es gibt nix, es gibt nix und
es kommt nix der Zeit, das ist auch nicht so wahnsinnig, das ist so, so langweilig dieser
Konsolen Release, ich weiß gar nicht, warum haben sich Leute, angeblich haben sich glaube
ich, um die 4 Millionen Leute eine PS5 gekauft, was machen die denn damit, nee die Konsolen
werden nicht aussterben, die ganzen Karnum-Spiele immer noch Konsolen, oder seid ihr her oder
was auch immer, Warzone spielen, ja, könnt ihr euch ja noch am Anfang an Stadia erinnern,
wo du es noch nicht mal richtig mit dem Smartphone verbinden konntest, das Zeug, das war so fail,
oder wo du dann diesen Stecker gebraucht hast zwischen Smartphone und Controller, wo es
dann so einen wackeligen Halter gab mit so einem Kabel dazwischen und sowas, weil Bluetooth
wieder richtig funktioniert hat, ganz ganz merkwürdiges Zeug.
Welche Distro ist mein Lieblingsdistro, Manjaro mit i3 WM, also das da, was ich hier verwende,
beste, beste, und Microsoft Frontpage natürlich, nee aber das hier, beste, oh Gesicht, das
erste was man findet, nein das ist der Fabian, das bin ich ich, habe ich mich in der Barbecue
so so mal gespiegelt, exellent, exellent, da ist er, kommt mal hier, da spiegelt er
sich, fuck, liegt, liegt, da ist er, 7 Jahre jüngere Max ist da, liegt, ich sag doch immer
ich seh fast so aus wie dense gaming, sieht man doch hier auch mal wieder, ich seh aus
wie dense gaming, nur mit ein bisschen mehr Haar noch, sicher, wieso kein Dark Mode, doch
Dark Mode, aber für Google hat er glaube ich ausgeschaltet, ah jetzt ist es viel besser,
naja also das wie gesagt aktuelle Konsolen Release mega langweilig, ja aber Stadia hat
halt einfach verschissen, Stadia isn't quite done, solche Aussagen bedeuten eigentlich
in der Regel, also eins kann man sich schmerken, umso mehr betont wird, dass die Sachen weiter
supportet werden und ganz furchtbar wichtig sind, umso schneller sind sie weg, was haben
die verkackt, naja es gab keinen an den sich das gerichtet hat so wirklich, dann auch am
Anfang, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert hat, dass du es nicht eine ganze Zeit lang
gar nicht auf dem PC spielen konntest im Chrome und so, ganz merkwürdig ist das, ich weiß
nicht was sie sich mit Stadia gedacht haben, hat Merkel schon ihr vollstes Vertrauen
ausgesprochen, ja gut dann ist eh vorbei, ja es ist bei mir so ein bisschen wie mit
der Switch, ich habe mir auch das Switch zum Release gekauft oder mehr oder weniger zum
Release und ich habe jetzt auch schon seit einem halben Jahr oder einem dreiviertel
Jahr nichts mehr, das letzte was ich hatte ist das Link's Awakening Remake ein paar
Stunden, das ist ja nicht lang das Game, da gibt es auch nichts, es gibt ja aktuell keine
Spiele für Konsolen außer halt die Dinge die es für alle Plattformen gibt, aber der
Switch ist ja fast am schlimmsten, Nintendo mit ihren zwei Games pro Jahr, da kommen noch
so Games mit so Nintendo Style Multiplayer raus wie Animal Crossing wo die Hälfte dann
funktioniert oder einfach schlecht durchdacht ist, naja
was für ein Ding
also man erkennt anhand des Links, dass es was anderes ist als was du vorgibst das es
ist, ach so jetzt habe ich es aufgemacht, habe ich falsch verstanden, ja das war tatsächlich
zähmbezogen, ja richtig die neuesten Max Leaks gibt es nur im privaten Discord Chat,
da müsst ihr es sammeln für, das stimmt das finde ich tatsächlich ganz cool, das war
übrigens über WebRTC glaube ich, im Prinzip ähnlich wie ich die Kameras auch bei mir
im Browser habe, ich habe mir das mal auf GitHub angeguckt vor einer Weile, OnlyFansAccount
ja, das sind eigentlich so die aktuellen GitHub Trends, bestimmt wieder C China Repos wo
ich schon nicht mal mehr die Repo Texte überhaupt lesen kann, oh Stonks Tracker für die Gamestop
Jungs, ok hier kann ich nicht mal lesen was es tut, ok wir machen mal Woche, Doga Coin
geht hoch, hat das auch was mit WallStreetBets zu tun, wenn Doga Coin hoch geht, es ist total
langweilig was da trendet, Jerrys Script, Ultra Lightweight JavaScript Engine, oh geil da kann
ich auf meinen ESPs endlich JavaScript laufen lassen, da habe ich ja schon die ganze Zeit
drauf gewartet, endlich ESPs mit JavaScript programmieren, China Repos, das habe ich
nicht verstanden Leute mit dem Raspberry Pi Pico, warum da so viele drauf abgehen, das
Ding kann legit nichts, warum man das kaufen sollte, verstehe ich nicht, also leuchtet
mir überhaupt nicht ein, wahrscheinlich einfach weil Raspberry Pi drauf steht, kostet auch
nix, aber die Alternativen können mehr und kosten genauso wenig, Cute Browser endlich,
endlich ein Browser für uns, für den, QB Fehler, was auch immer, Bildschirmspiegel
über dem Browser, es gibt eigentlich irgendwas was heute nicht im Browser läuft, es ist
echt langweilig an GitHub Trends gerade, neue Cryptocurrency, da hat die Welt natürlich
auch drauf gewartet, ja mega langweilig, ne nicht mehr so wirklich, es gab ja mal eine
Zeit lang gab es relativ viel Webkit basiertes Zeug, aber die haben hier ihre ganzen Bindings
nicht mehr aktualisiert, also sprich eigentlich nicht, es gibt so ein paar Firefox Forks noch,
aber es gibt mehr Chrome Reskins als Firefox Reskins, was sagst du zum neuen Gnome, ne
es gibt einen neuen Gnome, was ist das Gnome 4, ne Gnome 40, oh ja noch ein Redesign, da
haben wir drauf gewartet, das muss unbedingt sein, Gnome 3 geht mir schon so auf den Keks,
anstatt das mal ordentlich zu machen, es sieht doch im Prinzip noch aus wie Gnome 3, ok juckt
mich nicht, verwende ich nicht, versuche ich schon lange nicht mehr mitzuhalten was
sie da treiben, wie sieht ein Repo aus, welches, GitHub Repo, mein GitHub ist hier, wo Blurz
da, ah ja bestes Projektlogo übrigens aller Zeiten, ja also das, wenn es mal einen Award
gibt für das schönste GitHub Projektlogo, dann ist es eindeutig das hier, müsst ihr
zugeben oder, das ist wirklich noch nie da gewesen, das ist mein GitHub, aber da gibt
es jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel zu sehen, Friesi Lul, ja meine Projektnamen sind ja
schon die schönsten, Friesi Lul, Versandrexor, Monarch S, ach so mein Street Merchant Fork
gibt es hier, wo ich ein paar Sachen gefixt habe, ein paar Mindfactory Links und so, aber
den mache ich irgendwann den nächsten Tag in meinem Merchrequest auf, mit meinen Grafik
Skills auf jeden Fall, the fuck, ja das kennen wir schon, das habe ich schon ein paar mal
im Stream gezeigt, einfach nichts gibt hier, Leute ich glaube ich gehe jetzt ins Bett,
es ist jetzt 21.25, ich habe nichts mehr, was ich hier großartig machen könnte im Stream,
noch bin ich irgendwie sonderlich fit noch was zu machen, also nächsten Stream weiß
ich schon, nächsten Stream gucken wir uns, na gut kann sich ja immer schon ändern, an
dem nächsten Stream gucken wir uns mal, bin zu doof das Richtige anzuklicken, ja, nächsten
Stream gucken wir uns mal wirklich noch zwei weitere Hoster an, weil sich das die Leute
gewünscht haben im Chat, und wenn der Chat sich sowas wünscht, manchmal mache ich sowas
ja auch, wann gibt es eigentlich Q-Chat Primarch, es gibt ja nichts in Deutschland großartig
oder, wir gucken uns mal, wir gucken uns zwei Hoster an, neblich, jetzt kommt Strato, einmal,
das wird richtig Paynes Champ, das weiß ich jetzt schon, und Contabo hat letztens einer
Folge geschlagen, ich will da nichts hosten, ich habe mittlerweile mein Zeug gut verteilt,
aber angucken kann man sich ja mal, richtiger Hacker mein Desktop hier, Contabo hat Rebrand
gehabt, was haben sich denn Rebranded, welchen Hoster kannst du empfehlen, ich habe das meiste
bei Hetzner, ich habe das meiste bei Hetzner, ich habe einen Surfer bei 1&1 bei Ijonos,
aber auch nur weil der nur 1€ gekostet hat, den Rest habe ich alles bei Hetzner, letztens
habe ich bei OVH versucht, ich wollte das Preisschamp Frontend eigentlich bei OVH machen,
aber nachdem die gesagt haben, ich soll meinen Ausweis einscannen und rüber schicken, habe
ich dann gesagt, ne, dann bleibe ich halt auch mit dem Frontend bei Hetzner, Pündigung ist
raus, was geht eigentlich, ich habe mir gar keine Viewzahlen angeguckt, ich glaube nicht,
dass das Video viele geguckt haben oder, keine Hardware mehr verpassen, ne nicht so viele,
aber immerhin, ich meine es ist schon durchaus in Ordnung, 15.000 und 470 Comments, nicht
schlecht, zum Glück habe ich gefragt, ob ich ein Video zur technischen Umsetzung machen
sollte, weil ansonsten hätte es kaum Comments gegeben, ich denke mal die Hälfte der Comments
sind technische Umsetzungen Video, mach mal Max oder irgendwas in der Richtung, hast du
Analytics, ja aber nichts was die Leute einzeln internifizieren könnte, ich habe nur Connections
und User, aber ich speicher weder IP noch sonst was und wenn die User mal ordentlich
refreshen, dann ist es auch weg, also keine Unique ID´s und sonst was, also ich sehe
da nichts Großartiges, einzige was ich sehe ist, welchen Browser die Leute verwenden
beim Aufrufen und so halbwegs genau, so über den Daumen gepeilt, welches OS bzw. ob es
halt iOS, Android, Mobile ist oder was auch immer, stimmt ich muss neue Community Posts
machen für mehr Stonks, kennst du ein VPN Service mit dem man Netflix gucken kann,
ich würde mal ehrlich gesagt vermuten mit so gut wie jedem, weil das doch das hauptsächliche
Ding ist wo die Leute dazu bringen sich den Krams zu kaufen, stimmt du musst ne Umfrage
machen was der beste Stocktracker ist, ja da als Auswahl gibts 5x Preischamp, ich werd
da gar keine anderen rein machen, Netflix blockt fast alles, siehste wo wir wieder beim
Punkt sind, das beste ist einfach selbst machen, sich nen Server mieten, Digital Ocean oder
sonst wo, Hetzner, ne Hetzner hatten in den USA nix und dann selbst nen VPN dahin aufbauen,
easy, also so würd ichs wahrscheinlich machen wenn ich Netflix gucke, Pricechamp to the
Moon, sollte nicht, Moment sollte nicht eigentlich an Ende letzten Jahres das neue Spiel von
dem To the Moon Typ erscheinen, genau das da, ah ok ist noch nicht raus, exellent exellent,
Max muss nochmal tun da muss ich wieder heulen im Stream, unter Chat auch, keck wait, wobei
das ist dann jetzt das dritte Mal das ich das durchspiele ich glaube irgendwann hat
sich dann auch abgenutzt, man könnte nen Video machen, ich könnte das wirklich mal
in nem Video zeigen das das relativ einfach ist, Eats US Server mit VPN machen, Boomer
hier in explodiert, ok das muss ich auch noch machen, ganz wichtig, ja Abschlussprüfung
kann ich, konnte ich ja alles nicht zeigen, das ist ja IHK mäßig nicht möglich, IHK
Prüfung zeigen geht ja nicht wegen Copyright Stells, ich finds übrigens auch ein Unding
mal ganz ehrlich, dass es auf Prüfungen überhaupt so was wie nen Copyright gibt was die Leute
daran hindert die Prüfung auszutauschen, was soll das überhaupt, also ganz ehrlich,
Ausbildungsprüfungen von so ner, nennen wir es mal halbwegs offiziellen Seite sollten
komplett frei für alle zugänglich sein, ich verstehe, ich kann es nicht verstehen dass
sowas nicht geht, da könnte man nämlich zusammen im Stream sich das auch mal angucken ich könnte
ein bisschen was zu erzählen und sowas, den Node Exporter, von was wie, von was, von wo?
Was, Ionos hat auch, hat auch in den USA Server, zeig mal, wo kann man es auswählen zu den
Tarifen, Standort, konfigurieren, Standort, nee ich wills nicht in Deutschland, ich will
es woanders, USA, excellent und da drüber kann man da Netflix gucken, mal gucken ob
die IPs nicht gesperrt sind, das wird schon mal ausgebildet, Traffic, wie viel, wie viel
Traffic hatten die, steht das irgendwo, Traffic, naja wenn ich mir den Buch mit Prüfungsaufgaben
hol, dann kann ich die trotzdem nicht zeigen im Stream, ich dachte ich darf die dann den
Buch lesen, das habe ich dann aber auch von, wie viel Traffic haben die denn, wo steht
das, ja gleich bezahlen, excellent, ja ich würde echt gern, Daten, Daten, aber da stand
was mit Unlimited Traffic, okay, ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee, das müsste man mal ausprobieren,
so ein 1 Euro Server in den USA für Netflix, ah, Chat starten, beschreiben Sie ja an den
Keck weh, oh Sarah ist am Start, schönen guten Abend, gerne helfe ich Ihnen bei Ihrer
Frage weiter, wie darf ich Sie bitte ansprechen, nein wir machen im Schreibtisch nichts doofes
rein, jetzt regen sich wieder alle auf, Q Chat, darfst du mich ansprechen, übrigens
Leute, die haben ein Linked in Account gebannt, stellt euch das mal vor, Mr.
Kudor Chatte wurde gebannt, Kudor Chatte ist weg, ich meine ich hatte als Profilbild
das hier drinnen, es war vielleicht ein bisschen auffällig, dass das ein Fake Account ist,
aber macht euch nichts raus, ich habe schon den nächsten Linked in Fake Account am Start
für das Video, und diesmal heiße ich etwas realistischer, diesmal heiße ich glaube ich
Peter Wubble mit französischem E hinten dran, Peter Wubble, Wubble, und ich habe einfach
gar kein Profilfoto reingemacht, weil das sonst wieder zu auffällig wäre, den verrate
ich aber nicht in Account, sonst muss ich mir für jedes Video neuen Linked in Account
Fake Account machen, äh, Ausweis, Verifikation, ernsthaft, also ich habe es einfach so gemacht,
ich habe mir eine Fake Telefonnummer angelegt, gibt es ja genug Services wo man das machen
kann, Fake Telefonnummer angelegt, und einfach von der neuen IP über den Browser aufgemacht
und mit der Fake Telefonnummer mir SMS-Bestätigung geschicken lassen und zack, easy, habe es
noch ein Linked in Account, Fake Telefonnummer, es gibt Free Services, die sind aber alle
geplockt, aber das kostet nicht viel, müsst ihr mal ein bisschen rumgucken, gibt es genug,
so, geht mittlerweile schon komplette Privacy Services, die dir quasi ein komplettes Paket
generieren aus E-Mail, Domain, Adresse, Telefonnummer und alles mögliche, Fake Telefonnummer mit
richtigem Paypal nutzen, naja gut, bei Linked in werde ich ja auch keine kostenpflichtigen
Services machen, also, der Linked in Account ist am Start für das nächste Stellanzeigenvideo,
ja, und ich habe schon ein paar Coole rausgesucht, na gut, hier kann ich mich jetzt ja nicht einloggen,
das muss ich ja leaken, ah ne, da hat es das letzte Mal auch nicht gespeichert, ja, und
ich habe schon ein paar Stellanzeigen rausgesucht, da sind echt wieder Dinger drin und am besten
ist, dass irgendwie Linked in gerade verbackt ist und in der Hälfte der Stellanzeigen drin
steht, bitte aktivieren Sie Javascript, die Seite kann nicht angezeigt werden, ich weiß
jetzt nicht, ob das ein Bug von Linked in ist oder einfach die pure Unfähigkeit bei der
Personalabteilung, da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, aber das ist gefühlt die Hälfte
der Anzeigen, das ist irgendwelche Nintendo Playlist ist das, ich tendiere zuletzterem,
ja, da war übrigens auch Hetzner drin, Hetzner hat eine Stellanzeige gehabt und die hatte
das auch, da hätte ich eigentlich erwartet, dass sie das können, aber ich habe wieder,
ich habe echt, also ich habe schon drei richtig beknackte Stellanzeigen und ich werde es
nach Möglichkeit so machen, ich werde, ups, ich bin zu über das Kabel gefahren, ich werde
nach Möglichkeit auch immer ein paar Gescheite reinnehmen, weil es hat ja keinen Sinn, wenn
ich da irgendwie ein Viertelstunde alles nur bashe, habt ihr eigentlich gesehen, dass
sie sich gemeldet haben, im letzten, im letzten Video hat sich der, einer von denen, die ich
ein bisschen ehrlich gesagt fast schon ein bisschen zu hart dran genommen habe, haben
sich gemeldet im, in den Comments, irgendwo, ja
hier, die da, Konfin Pro haben sich gemeldet, exzellent, lass uns mal gerne, da habe ich
keinen Bock drauf, aber, die haben es wenigstens, die haben es wenigstens mit Humor genommen,
ja, haben drauf geantwortet, ich meine das Video habe schon 110.000 Leute gesehen, das
ist ganz schön viel, die haben, auf Twitter haben die auch geantwortet, ja, also wie gesagt,
ich habe, nächstes Video, also ich habe einen Fehler in dem Video gemacht, ich habe,
ich habe Stellen aus Frankfurt gesucht, das ist taktisch nicht so geschickt, weil, sollt,
stellt euch mal vor, ich habe, da machte jetzt eine Videoserie, mit irgendwie 20 Teilen und
ich will mir mal einen neuen Job suchen und ich habe quasi schon so 90% der Arbeitgeber
in Frankfurt geflamed, ich glaube, das ist keine allzu gute Idee, ähm, deswegen, ich
habe jetzt im nächsten Video, habe ich auch, national, deutschlandweit, geguckt bei LinkedIn,
wie gesagt, nächstes Video, mache ich hauptsächlich LinkedIn anzeigen und vielleicht noch ein
paar andere, wenn es noch ein paar total abgedrehte Sachen gibt, ach Kritik darf man, aber, ich
darf das schon, aber, soll er nicht gut ankommen, tut das nicht, ich meine, ich, ich habe es
ja an manchen Stellen auch schon ein bisschen übertrieben, äh, das gefällt ihm bestimmt
nicht, du musst bei YouTube mehr Werbung für dein Twitch Stream machen, ach, ich find's
eigentlich gut, wie das ist, oder Chat, es kommen genau die richtigen Leute von YouTube,
die nervigen Leute checken es nicht und die guten Leute kommen rüber, dauert halt ein
bisschen, aber, besser als andersrum, dass die ganzen nervigen Leute auch am Start sind,
dann wär's ja nicht mal der Q-Chat, Q-Chat, genau, so sieht's aus, ja komm, 666 Comments
hätten ja wenigstens mal sein können, ich brauch noch irgendeinen guten Titel für das
nächste, für das nächste, also, ich brauch irgendwas, was man kennt, für das nächste
Stellenanzeigen Video, weil, guck mal hier, ich hab ja hier in dem Thumbnail, in dem Thumbnail
hab ich ja die Bahn drin, das erkennt man sofort, dass das die Bahn ist, also selbst
wenn das ganz klein ist auf der Seite, ja, und ich brauch für das nächste wieder irgendwie
zumindest eine Sache, die man kennt, wo ich was einblenden kann, es muss halt was sein,
was man kennt und was schlecht ist, die Tele, oh ja die Telekom, ja, theoretisch, aber so
schlecht sind die Telekom-Dinger gar nicht, so sieht's aus, Cross Promotia schon, Apple,
ich glaub die sind aber, die Apple Stellenanzeigen sind nicht cringe genug, Vodafone, ok Moment,
da muss ich jetzt mal ganz schnell gucken, wir haben noch 5 Minuten Zeit, Vodafone, haben
die was?
Ok, da muss ich mal ganz schnell gucken kurz, ob die irgendwelche cringe Stellenanzeigen
haben, in guten, wir suchen durch, ok, alles klar, so, was haben die denn hier, Ausbildung,
Dualtest, Berufseinsteiger, Erfahrene, zeigen wir mal eine Möglichkeit, auch besonders divers
immer, das heißt ich kann mich dann auch als Helikopter bewerben oder wie ist das, exzellent,
betrachte dein Match, passt du zu Vodafone, ok, ok, das müssen wir jetzt mal machen, Company
Match, passt Vodafone GmbH zu dir, ok, das machen wir jetzt schnell, wir haben noch 15
Stunden Zeit, jetzt mal kurz gucken, was die für Jobs bei Vodafone haben, Technik-IT,
ja, ich hab irgendwie, Nass juckt, ok, das ist das gleiche, Senior Digital Solution Consult
mit Fokus Cloud Security, Abteilungsleiter, gibt es irgendwas für mich, Agile Tools and
Collaboration, Senior Expert, ja, das ist aber, da geht es zur Sache, Data and Data Scientist,
ok, gibt es da irgendwas, IT Support Process, die sind wahrscheinlich irgendwie Teamleiter
für die Hotline oder so, ok, Systems Engineer, da kann man noch ein bisschen was mit anfangen,
Experte Value Added Services, was, was soll das sein, in Ashborne, ok, das ist nicht so
weit weg von uns, was ist Experte Value Added Services, kann man da wirklich legit nichts
darunter vorstellen, Lead Developer, ok, da kommt nichts scheiß mehr, ok, lass mal schnell
rein, 8, das filmt schon wieder, Alter, oh man, nee, ich gucke nur rein fürs nächste
Video, wir haben noch ein Viertelstunde Zeit, du fragst dich schon seit Jahren, wie man
ohne Atlassian Tools in einem Developer, nein, nein, nein, das ist falsch, ich weiß, dass
man definitiv ohne Atlassian Tools vernünftig arbeiten kann, mit der vermehrten Einführung
agiler Methoden und dass sie stetig verändern, steigen die Anforderungen an unser Atlassian
Tools, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, für was es steht, das taucht da laufend auf Safe,
ich müsste mir langsam mal merken, aber ich habe vergessen, für was Safe steht, Jyra,
Leute, sorry, Jyra, Confluence, kann man Confluence irgendwie auch besonders geil aussprechen,
oder, ich bin ja für Confluence, hilft uns, ok, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, ok, das
ist aber noch relativ normal, was für mich, die wollen auch wieder ganz schön viele auf
einmal haben, gibt's nicht, Experte, Systems Engineer, das sieht aber alles so normal aus,
da kann ich mich gar nicht mehr großartig drüber lustig machen, du bist ein Technik-Enthusiast
und IVR ist für dich kein Fremdort, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich habe keine Ahnung, was
das ist, Internet, Internet, Virtual Reality, Phoenix, 12 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub,
Massive Subscription hier, zeig mal, wo haben wir es denn, ich habe Cyberport aufgenommen,
Cyberport ploppt da ab und zu mal auf, die sind aber recht aggressiv mit Sperren, es
kann sein, dass das zwischenzeitlich nicht geht, den Workstream innerhalb einer Abteilung,
aha, OISDN, Execquisite, ok, jetzt machen wir den Company Match mit Vodafone, alles klar,
also, ich gehe am liebsten folgendermaßen mit meinen Kollegen um, geschäftlich, freundschaftlich,
also in der Mitte ist schon ok, eher ein bisschen Richtung geschäftlich, allerdings
nicht zu Business Stonks, so Mitte, Mitte ist ok, mit ein paar versteht man sich gut,
mit ein paar willst du nichts zu tun haben, die Kollegen in meinem Idealenteam zeichnen
sich hauptsächlich aus durch Präzision, Unternehmergeist, Sozialverhalten, Leidenschaft,
gesellig, Sozialverhalten, ich habe keinen Bock auf viele Spasten, also man kann auch
mehr Leidenschaft, ich will die nicht gatschi bassen, die sollen ordentlich arbeiten, Gune
Balzer, ob die Unternehmergeist haben ist mir vollkommen wurscht, meine Ideen zeichnen
sich aus durch bahnbrechende Ideen, gute Laune, ja, ohne Scheiß, mittlerweile ist es bei mir
so, ich lege da echt Wert drauf, dass mir keiner auf den Sack geht, ich habe auch keinen
Bock mich permanent, früher hatte ich da keine, hatte so viele Schmerzen, aber ich habe keinen
Bock mich permanent mit irgendwelchen Leuten da irgendwie auseinanderzusetzen, die meinen,
sie müssten jetzt irgendwie hier alles die ganze Zeit rum nerven, irgendwie, am liebsten
sind mir Leute, mit denen man gut klar kommt und die gut drauf sind, ich muss mit denen
auch gar nicht, sondern nicht dicke sein, aber mir geht es persönlich erstmal darum,
dass ich weniger Stress habe, dass es natürlich für die Firma geiler ist, wenn die bahnbrechenden
Ideen haben, sei mal außen vor, ja, klare Vereinbarungen, Fokus auf Ergebnisse, bahnbrechende
Ideen sind auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, Fokus auf klare Vereinbarungen, ja klare Vereinbarungen
mit Kollegen brauche ich, ich brauche in manchen Bereichen klare Vorgaben, wenn von einem gefordert
wird, dass man sich an was halten soll, weil es gibt nichts beschisseneres und das kennt
wahrscheinlich auch jeder von euch, wenn es heißt, ja, wir haben dafür doch ganz viele
super tolle Prozesse und da müsst ihr euch jetzt dran halten und so müsst ihr es machen
und das müsst ihr nicht machen und wenn du mal fragst, ja, ok, wo steht das jetzt, wie
ich es genau machen soll, ja, ne, da steht nirgendwo, ist ja ok, aber wozu haben wir
dann so geile Prozesse gemacht, wenn die nirgendwo stehen und wo soll ich dann wissen, was ich
machen muss, das ist auch immer geil, weißt du, naja, ich bin ja eigentlich keiner, der
so großartig dafür ist, alles wahnsinnig geil durchzuplanen und zu sagen, hier jeder
Handgriff muss fünfmal peer reviewed sein oder so und alles muss super stonks, eitel
konform sein, da bin ich ja überhaupt nicht ein Fan von, aber wenn man sagt, dass es
so sein soll, dann muss man da wenigstens sich die Frage fallen lassen, ok, wo steht
es denn jetzt, no code, ich glaube nicht, dass ich das in irgendeiner Art und Weise
durchsetzen wird, das ist genauso wie serverless, das auch nicht wirklich serverless ist, ok,
meine Idee, legt den Schwerpunkt auf, das ist so total random, das kommt drauf an, was
gerade angesagt ist, ich finde es auf jeden Fall gut, wenn man die Leute zuhört, wenn
das Zeug, was man baut, gut funktioniert und auch ordentlich support werden kann, ist auch
gut, irgendwie so, das stimmt, eitel ist so ein Ding, da steht ja viel drin, wenn der
Tag lang ist und eine der Sachen, die da glaube ich auch drin steht, die ziemlich am Anfang
ist und was eigentlich auch jeder Trainer sagt, man soll nicht einfach nur was machen,
weil es da drin steht, sondern es muss zu dem ehemaligen Laden passen, was sagen Sie
zu Linus Tech Tips, das wäre mal eine Frage, ja, meine ideale Führungskraft konzentriert
sich hauptsächlich auf Koordination, dafür ist eine Führungskraft da, ganz ehrlich,
das ist nice, wenn das vielleicht eine Führungskraft macht, aber wenn eine Führungskraft fast
nicht koordiniert, ist die komplett falsch an der Stelle, so wie ich Technik Hackermann
machen soll, soll eine Führungskraft das machen, wofür er da ist, nämlich koordinieren
und es hat jeder sein Aufgabengebiet und wenn eine Führungskraft fast nicht koordiniert,
dann läuft es eben nicht, Inspiration, Leistung, Team Building auch gut, dein Chef macht Technik
Hackermann Chaos am Start, ja ist echt so, mein Chef macht das mittlerweile glücklicherweise
nicht, der konzentriert sich hauptsächlich aufs organisieren und koordinieren und das
klappt erstaunlich gut, besser als beim letzten, der letzte Chef, den ich hatte, der aktuelle
ist übrigens der, der auch Battlefield gespielt hat früher, von dem ich auf irgendeinem USB
Stick einen Heli Battlefield 3 Heli Gameplay habe, der macht das gut, aber der davor, der
war auch schon ein bisschen älter und das war so Gruppenleiter mit Erziehungstick, der
wollte die Leute immer erziehen, wenn er gemeint hat, die machen das nicht so wie er das will,
das ging mir auf den Sack, ok, das Hauptziel meines Idealen Vorgesetzten, jetzt haben die
mich das nicht eben schon gefragt, was soll ich denn da drauf antworten, alter, Kontinuität
garantieren, es ist wichtig, dass man weiß, was Sache ist, was zum Teufel soll ich da,
der schaut manchmal auch die Videos, ja ok, ich hab keine Ahnung, alter, was soll ich
da, ok, der soll Ergebnisse fördern, ich hab keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt, Chancen
nutzen, Teams coachen und alles klar, wirklich keine Ahnung, Ausflug in den Kletterpark,
oh hör mal auf, das erinnert mich an Sachen wieder, xxxxx, drei Monate, danke schön
für den Sub, also in deiner arbeitsbezogenen Diskussion ist die Wahrheit wichtiger als
die Sensibilität, da mach ich mich unbeliebt ja, aber, so doof das klingt, also ich hab
ja, also da muss ich jetzt, das ist schwierig zu sagen, ich hab ja gesagt mir ist es unglaublich
wichtig, dass man gut mit den Leuten auskommt, aber ich glaube gerade, wenn man mit den Leuten
gut auskommt und man auch so einen gewissen Draht zu den Leuten hat, dann ist es auch
wichtig zu sagen, wenn was kacke ist, es muss halt so einen Rahmen geben, dass man halt auch
mal was sagen kann, ich weiß es passt eigentlich nicht zu dem, was ich vorher gesagt hab, aber
wenn die anderen Sachen vorher erfüllt sind, dann finde ich, dann sollte das schon so sein,
weil es hat keiner was davon, wenn man drei Meetings macht und die ganze Zeit nur mit
heißen Brei rumredet und nichts bei rauskommt. So, die Fähigkeit einen guten Plan zu erstellen
und ihn weiter zu folgen ist der wichtigste Teil eines Projekts. Entgegen dem, was viele
Business Stonks Leute sehen, ja, ich sehe das so, dass ein Großteil dessen, was in
die Hose geht bei Projektmanagement ist, dass die Leute sich am Anfang keine richtigen
Gedanken drum machen und dass dann Dinger erzählt werden, so nach dem Motto, wir machen
einen MP3 Player mit Kaffeemaschine und irgendwann kommt er dann raus und sagt, das gibt ja
überhaupt keinen Sinn. Also man sollte schon einen guten Plan haben, bevor man was anfängt.
Einfach random irgendwas anfangen, ohne jegliche Ideen ist halt Crap. Warum werden Start-ups
gegründet? Weil jemand eine gute Idee hat, nicht weil er sich denkt, ich bin heute aufgestanden
und möchte gerne einen Start-up gründen. Gibt's Ausnahmen, bestätigen die Regel. Unerwartete
Situationen sind kein Problem, ich bin flexibel und bereit zu... Bin ich? Bin ich? Wenn, wenn
die andere Seite das auch ist, ich hab kein Problem zu sagen, ey ich arbeite auch mal
keine andere Wocheende oder mal Nacht oder irgendwas, wenn irgendwas kaputt ist, hab
ich keine Schmerzen mit, so lange das nicht dauerhaft ist und so lange die andere Seite
dann auch sagt, ok ich komm dir auch manchmal entgegen. Vollkommen in Ordnung. Wenn das
natürlich nur einseitig ist, ja, dann nicht, dann hab ich das 2-3 mal gemacht und mach's
nicht mehr. Das sind so Sachen, die kann man so pauschal allgemein gar nicht sagen,
großartig. Meine Arbeit ist so spezifiziert, dass ich nur mit direkten Kollegen ein professionelles
Gespräch führen kann. Ja, kommt drauf an, welche Arbeit es ist. Kommt drauf an, was
ich mache. Wenn ich grad irgendwas programmieren soll, wo nur 5 Leute Bescheid wissen, ja
was soll ich dazu sagen, ey. Gut, es gibt Leute, mit denen kann ich kein professionelles
Gespräch führen. Wenn sich beispielsweise vom Außendienst wieder einer verwählt hat
und bei mir am Telefon dran ist, dem kann ich schlicht und ergreifend nicht helfen.
Da sag ich dann hier, sie haben sich glaub verwählt, sie sind der Technik rausgekommen.
Ach, weiter. Andere beschreiben dich oft als ruhig und kontrolliert. Ich würd schon sagen.
Ich bin eigentlich, keine Ahnung. Chat, was sagt ihr? Beschreib mich mal. Ja, sehr gut,
alles klar. Beschreibung Boomer. Okay, weiter. In sozialen Situationen greifst du schnell.
Nein. Die sollen alle mal ihren Kram alleine machen, ey. Und mich nicht nerven. Ständig
am Ausrasten und Leute beleidigen. Ja, man kennt's, man kennt's. In meiner beruflichen
Tätigkeit hab ich gerne ein sehr breites Aufgaben. Ehrlich gesagt, ich beiß mich gerne
an Sachen fest. Ich beiß mich gerne an Sachen fest. Aber das muss dann auch nicht unbedingt
drei Jahre gehen oder so. Aber mal ne gewisse Zeit, ne gewisse Zeit so wirklich fokussiert
die Dinger machen, ja. Ich bleib mal in der Mitte. In meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit ist
die Beziehung zu Menschen das Wichtigste. Ne. Die Technik muss funktionieren. Ich will
natürlich mit den Leuten auch gut klarkommen, aber das ist jetzt nicht der Hauptbestandteil.
Mir ist wichtig, dass ich gut mit den Leuten klarkomme, aber das muss was Technisch ordentlich,
wenn's kompiliert ist, geht's, ja. Was für bescheuerte Fragen, ey. Reicher Geschichte
und Kultur. Was? Moment, hä? Der Ehrgeiz meiner Idealen ist geprägt von reicher Geschichte
und Kultur. Ach so, so. Was die für ne History haben. So nach dem Motto, wir waren das erste
Unternehmen was XY gemacht hat und wir sind die geilsten. Das sagen aber doch alle. Sorge
um die umweltunternehmerische. Ehrlich gesagt, für meine ideale Organisation ist das Wichtigste
unternehmerische Initiative, weil ich will, dass wenn's mir da gefällt, dass es die noch
ne Weile gibt, wenn's mir da gefällt, wenn's ja meine ideale Organisation ist, wenn die
nur Geschichte, Kultur, Sorge um die Umwelt und Engagement machen, dann gibt's die nicht
mal lang. Also das Wichtigste von der Firma ist eindeutig unternehmerische Initiative.
Ehrlich gesagt, ob die reiche Geschichte und Kultur haben, ist mir scheißegal, dass sie
sich um Umweltschutz Gedanken machen, find ich dann schlecht, soziale Sauern, okay, exzellent.
Meine ideale, Gesundheit, meine, nicht Gesundheit, meine ideale Organisation steht für, äh,
what? Weder noch, mir soll's da Spaß machen und die sollen gut bezahlen. Ja, okay, die
sollen gut bezahlen. Persönlicher Wohlstand, ja. Ähm, ja, ich bin ja Umweltschutz an sich
eh nicht abgeneigt. Okay, Werte und Tradition sind mir vollkommen egal. Meine ideale Organisation
erreicht Wachstum durch Innovation, zufriedene Mitarbeiter, ähm, Innovation ohne zufriedene
Mitarbeiter und das geht nicht. Dort wo Leute permanent nur am rumkotzen und rumk- kommt
keine Innovation raus. Das funktioniert nicht. Oder, oder meint ihr aus dem, äh, indischen
Facebook Upload Filter Kontrollierteam ist jemals Innovation gekommen? Bis denn, Captain
Peng, meine ideale Organisation erreicht Wachstum durch. Alter, was bescheuerte Fragen ey. Investition
in Teams. Nee, die müssen die besten sein. Nur so viel verdienst du Dick Stonks. Anders
geht das nicht. Dann musst du dich gut um deine Leute kümmern. Was auch immer Bereitstellung
von Struktur sein soll. Inspirierende Sachen soll es vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, was die
von mir wollen. Ich arbeite gern von, äh, ja, von daheim aus. Ähm, welche Art von Dynamik
suchst du bei deinem zukünftigen Arbeitgeber? Ist mir ehrlich gesagt vollkommen egal, solange
man mit den Leuten gut klarkommt. Wir hatten schon alle möglichen Leute am Start da. Wir
hatten, äh, Russen, Engländer, ähm, wie heißen Leute von der Elfenbeinküste, Elfenbeinküstler,
alles. Wir hatten wirklich schon mehr oder weniger alles am Start. Und es gab bei allen
richtige Deppen und es gab bei allen Leuten, mit denen man gut klarkommt. Glücklicherweise
kommt man zum größten Teil mit den Leuten eigentlich ganz gut klar. Elfen von der Elfenbeinküste,
genau. Nö, also, ist mir eigentlich, eigentlich gesagt egal. Was ich bei den Russen gemerkt
habe bei uns, die sind alle, waren die ultra vorsichtig. Der eine war echt ganz extrem,
das war auch der Netteste von allen, muss ich sagen. Aber der war echt extrem. Der hat
neben dir gesessen, der hat schräg neben mir gesessen und wenn der gesehen hat bei
mir auf dem Monitor, dass ich den übelsten Scheiß getippt habe, der hat nicht gesagt,
magst du Tipps Scheiße. Der hat dich von der Seite so schräg angeguckt, bis du dich dann
umgedreht hast und hast gemeint so, Alexei, gibts irgendwas? Dann meinte er so, ja, also
das was du geschrieben hast, das könnte man vielleicht auch anders schreiben. Das hieß
bei dem im Endeffekt übersetzt, du machst totalen Mist. Der war echt nett und hatte
echt planer Typ. Ja, geht auch als Einzeiler, das war das, ja. Okay, mein idealer Arbeitsplatz
lässt sich am besten beschreiben als, ja ja, Hightech, easy. Ich habe auf traditionell
und mit Steintafeln keinen Bock. Mein idealer Arbeitgeber hat hauptsächlich feste Arbeitsplätze,
flexible Arbeitsplätze. Alles eine Frage der Bezahlung, ja. Es ist, finde ich nicht
verkehrt, wenn langfristig das meiste oder Großteil davon feste Leute sind, weil du
hast oftmals das Problem, dort wo nur flexible Konsulten, Stonksleute rumrennen. Ach, Moment,
Arbeitsplätze. Okay, meint der jetzt, meint der jetzt, das Verhältnis von intern zu extern
oder meint der das, wo man sitzt? Was meinen die denn? Meinen die, wo man sitzt oder meinen
die verhältnisinterne externe Arbeit, Leute? Da hätten die Stellen geschrieben, die meinen
sitzen, die meinen wo man sitzt, die meinen wo man sitzt. Ja, ganz ehrlich, ich sitze
ganz gern, nachdem ich mich, nachdem ich viel Wert drauf leg, dass ich mich mit den Leuten
gut verstehe, auch ganz gerne so ungefähr bei den gleichen Leuten, deswegen das finde
ich ganz gut, wenn der, wenn man, wenn man zumindest halbwegs weiß, wo einer ist und
so, das finde ich nicht verkehrt. Aber die Möglichkeit sich ab und zu mal umzusetzen
ist auch nicht verkehrt. Okay, in meiner Arbeit fühle ich mich am wohlsten mit festen Aufgaben,
Wechselaufgaben. Wie gesagt, beides, ich mache am liebsten eine Zeit lang feste Sachen,
wo ich mich dann, wo ich dann echt Big Brain einsteigen kann, aber das muss auch dann nicht
fünf Jahre am Stück sein, ja. Wie gesagt, jetzt wo ich den Preischamp gebastelt habe,
ich mache 14 Tage abends, habe ich mich nur um den Preischamp gekümmert, nebenbei ein
paar Videos gemacht, aber das ist dann auch mal wieder gut irgendwann. Ja, und jeden Tag
festen Wechselaufgaben funktioniert ja auch nicht, du musst ja schon ungefähr wissen,
was du machst und dich ein bisschen auch an die Abläufe und so gewöhnen, also super extrem
Agile nur um Agile zu sein ergibt ja auch keinen Sinn. Wählen, wähle die Werte, die am besten
zu dir passen. Sozial, realistisch, rücksichtsvoll, erfolgreich, praktisch, stolz, Widmung. Was,
was macht man denn bei Widmung? Ok, realistisch. Praktisch. Muss ich, muss ich da irgendwie
noch mehr auswählen? Sorgenfrei, flexibel, aufregend. Ne, ne, zu, Sicherheit. Keine Ahnung.
Warum ist das Magenta? Ich denke, das ist Vodafone. Haben wir es heute? Bald mal, ich
muss gleich ins Bett. Wähle die Fragen, die am besten zu dir passen. Neugierig? Ja, wenn
es mich interessiert, exquisite. Ja, ich mache die Sachen ordentlich. Wisst ihr warum ich
die Sachen ordentlich mache? Weil ich eine faule Sau bin. Und umso fauler man ist, umso
ordentlicher macht man die Sachen, weil man will sich nie wieder drum kümmern, äh, nie
wieder drum kümmern müssen. Neugierig? Ich mag das auch, wenn Sachen einfach sind. Ich
mache auch gerne Sachen, also ich habe keine Probleme, das als erster zu machen. Auch gerade
neue Technik finde ich nice. Ich habe nicht umsonst Webcam, WebRTC-Ding gebaut, was sonst
keiner macht. Okay, weiter. Trans, also wir haben es heute mal, es reicht jetzt langsam,
ich verführe euch jetzt zum Prime-Subben. Schafsinnig, ich, es ist immer doof sich sowas
selbst anzudichten, ja. Jo 27 Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub, das ist immer, würde ich
auch sagen, ja. Ach Kerl. Ja, ich habe keinen Bock auf andere Leute normalerweise. Konnte
nicht widerstehen, der K-Cop da, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub. Fast fertig, okay. Was?
Okay, IT, irgendwas. IT und Softwareentwicklung, wähle eine Branche, Hörnberatung, Consulting,
Internet und IT. Aktuell bin ich berufserfahren weiter. Okay, was kommt da jetzt raus, dass
ich überhaupt nicht zu wo davon pass? Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs, Leute, was ist denn
hier los jetzt? Leko hat ein Abo verschenkt und zwar, wer kriegt, der Wambo hat eins gekriegt,
nice, Dankeschön für den Gift-Sub. Was? Ich will das Ergebnis, ich will mich nicht
registrieren, Skamars. Starmark, fünf Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, überspringen. Lukasso
47, auch bei dir, danke für den Sub. 980 Match, Leute, Bewerbung ist raus. Bewerbung
ist direkt, Bewerbung ist raus, zu wo davon? Match Report. Okay, zeig her. Na meine Werte
sind mit wo davon nicht so geil. Wachstumsstrategie. Na gut, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, ich passe
besser zu wo davon als zur Telekom. Mit der Telekom haben wir auch schon sowas mal gemacht
und da kam nichts Gutes bei raus, weiß ich noch. Fast sowas wie Tinder hier gewesen.